So, Leute, weiter geht's.
Oder was heißt weiter, weiter geht's?
Das erweckt ja den Anschein, als würde es mit irgendwas vorwärts gehen.
Ah, das ist ja nicht...
Ist ja nicht so.
Ja, alle sind ja sogar mal fertig geworden im letzten Stream.
Du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du.
Geht der Chat überhaupt?
Okay, Twitch hat einfach schlicht und ergreifend den Stream noch nicht angekündigt, Saurei.
Oh, hier, Michael 50 Billion ist am Start.
Moment, stimmt das überhaupt?
1, also 5, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 5 Billionen.
50, 500 Millionen, ne, stimmt gar nicht.
Exposed.
Ich muss erst noch mal den Streamingrechner starten.
Weil ich was sehe, deswegen habe ich den Chat hier gerade mal auf Fullscreen.
Ich habe übrigens vorher meine Grafik gerade übertaktet.
Weil ich mal gucken wollte, wie weit es geht.
Und ich muss sagen, es geht erstaunlich weit.
Moment, ich habe 1.080 TI.
Die hat Base Clock, 1.480 MHz, Boost, 1.500 irgendwas.
Und ich habe einfach mal das Energielimit hochgeschraubt und den Takt plus 150 gesetzt.
Und dann hatte ich am Ende anstatt 1.500, 2.012 Takt von der GPU.
Das Ding wurde halt laut wie Sau, der Lüfter, ne.
Ich habe noch nie gehört, wie meine Grafik gerade auf 100% Lüfterlautstärke.
Lagfest, weiß ich nicht.
So, mal gucken hier.
Ich habe meinen Vorschau leider noch nicht an.
Ne, das funktioniert hier alles.
Daniel Lull, Dankeschön.
Huge Subscription.
Wie gesagt, ich bin gerade auch dabei, mal ein Schriebenrechner zu schlagen.
Excellent Subscription.
Ja, ich kann euch das mal zeigen, wie weit ich meine Grafik übertakten kann.
Ich zeige euch das mal kurz.
Excellent Übertaktung.
Wobei, ich GPU encode.
Das ist keine allzu gute Idee.
Ich zeige euch mal, was ich eingestellt habe.
Ich aktiviere es aber nicht.
Ich zeige euch nochmal, was ich eingestellt habe.
Weil es wäre eine blöde Idee, das jetzt im Stream zu machen, nachdem ich GPU encoding.
Was du willst, ein extra Streaming-Rechner?
Ne, will ich nicht, habe ich schon.
Schon die ganze Zeit.
Das ist mein alter Desktop-Rechner.
Also, das stimmt nicht ganz.
Das ist kein Streaming-Rechner, in dem sie sich darüber streamen.
Das benutze ich für Vorschau, Audio-Settings und sowas.
Streamen, in dem Fall macht ihr tatsächlich OBS auf dem eigentlichen Spiele-Rechner auch.
So, jetzt habe ich es auf.
Wunderbar.
Excellent, jetzt können wir jetzt zu machen.
Die E-Modes ein bisschen kleiner.
Und eben bei, wo ich euch das zeige, mache ich mal kurz ein Update von meiner Linux-File.
Weil die brauchen wir gleich.
Yes.
Excellent.
Wir haben schon eine Weile nicht mehr geupdatet.
Die Musik muss ich ein bisschen leiser machen.
So ist gut.
Na, so passt das.
Ach ja, Moment.
Teams.
Teams hat bestimmt mal ein Mikro von mir.
Ach ja, Moment.
Teams, Teams hat bestimmt mal ein Mikro von mir wieder lauter gestellt.
So eine abgrundtiefe Scheißsoftware.
Okay, okay.
Da müssen wir jetzt mal kurz eine Lösung suchen.
Prevent applications from changing mic volume.
Auto-Stop-Microphone from auto-adjusting.
Excellent.
Appu, App, App, Appu, was?
Appuels, App, ich kann es nicht aussprechen.
Appschuels, Appschuels, Casuals, Appschuels.
Kackwort.
Sackt, Alter.
Piss dich, Aldo.
Okay.
Hier steht, wie es geht.
Also.
Skype.
Lull.
Skype verwenden wir nicht.
Ich will das global in Windows machen.
Nein.
Ich will das lokal in Windows machen.
Ansonsten machen wir wirklich ein PowerShell-Skript.
Was?
Einstellung?
Okay, okay, okay.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Also.
Wo jetzt?
Wo muss ich hin?
Erste Kontrolle, da.
Exzellent.
Da.
Advanced.
Da, Advanced, Didididididididididid.
Wie laut.
Äh.
Ach Moment, es geht übrigens um das Mikrofon.
Es geht um das Mikrofon und da ist der Haken nämlich schon raus, es geht ja um das Mikrofon,
aber Teams und Skype kann es trotzdem verändern.
Haben wir das schon mal in Stream Ideen aufgeschrieben?
Ja, Toilettprogramm, das schaut, wenn Anwendung beendet wird und Mikrofonvolumen zurück herstellt.
Krasses Deutsch Max.
Okay, das muss man wirklich selbst machen, anscheinend wie es aussieht.
In Teams kannst du keine Pegel setzen, Teams macht so viel, wie es denkt.
Das ist richtig Monarchs Teams.
Mal gucken, wie das mit dem Kompilier läuft.
Oh, schon fertig geupdatet, das ging aber schnell.
Ich behaupte, G-Baited so schnell hat es bestimmt nicht geupdatet.
Mal gucken, welche Körner wir noch drauf haben.
Alles gut, die aktuelle, wunderbar, Rebooten wir mal.
Ich wollte euch noch irgendwas zeigen, ich wollte euch Grafikkarten über Takten zeigen
und ich wollte euch gerade noch irgendwas anderes zeigen, weil ich hab ja der updatet länger.
Hintergrundbild aktualisieren, funktioniert alles, wunderbar, Chrome oft machen, Restore.
Oh, was haben wir hier nicht installiert, oh guck mal da, was ist das, mein Farbschema
ist nicht da.
Home Max Repos Base 16 Shell, Exposed, tatsächlich, warum ist das nicht da, muss ich mal kurz
klonen.
Ohne ordentliches Konsolenfarbschema kann ich hier nicht arbeiten, das funktioniert
nicht.
Ah, ja so ist das doch, so ist das doch viel, ist das doch viel besser.
So, mein Vorschaufenster geht auch, sehr schön, nice, alles gut.
Ich kann übrigens jetzt auch vorwärts und zurück springen, weil ich endlich mal geschafft
hab auf meiner VM hier die ganzen Konfig zu sunken, geht übrigens hier mit total einfach.
Kann man einfach Konfig von GitHub klonen und das verlinkt das alles richtig in allen
Ordnern wie es sein muss.
So, ich wollte jetzt mal gucken, ob der wirklich alles geupdatet hat, was er updaten soll.
Nee, hat er natürlich nicht, das ist einfach pure Chebat wieder, einfach kompletter Chebat.
Wie ging das, no, confirm, no, confirm, wenn ich schreiben könnte, ich will nicht bei allem
yes drücken müssen.
Nee, okay, anscheinend nicht, so, ich kann es nicht merken, na gut, dann mach halt von
Hand, alles gut, mach Bild, ja ja, alles gut.
Genau, so, also, Grafikkarte übertacken wollte ich euch zeigen und was wollte ich euch noch
zeigen?
Wollte ich irgendwas hier zeigen?
Achso, wo ich es gerade sehe, habt ihr das schon gesehen, was für geile Sachen es wieder
auf Steam gibt?
Das ist jetzt kein Fake-Bild, was ich gemacht hab, das sieht wirklich so schlecht aus, das
ist eins zu eins auf Steam.
Wenn ihr auf Steam geht und sucht danach, findet ihr das, den Chair-Fucking-Simulator.
Also, ich weiß, es sieht aus wie manipuliertes Bild, aber geht in Steam und sucht danach,
das gibt es wirklich, it's coming, release date, ich dachte eigentlich, dass seit Greenlight
weg ist, der ganze Shit von Steam verschwindet, aber ist nicht so, ich kann den noch nicht
spielen, der ist ja nicht raus, der Chair-Fucking-Simulator, er hat schon der Name, wie das Gameplay ist,
laut den Bildern ist mal irgend so ein untexturiertes Ding, was es mit Stühlen treibt.
Was ist hier los?
Warum spackt der schon wieder rum?
Was soll das?
Warum ist der hier schon wieder rumgespackt?
One or more files did not pass Valetee-Check, warum?
Die sollen gefälligst Valetee-Check passen, ich will, dass das Valetee-Check passt, warum
macht es das nicht?
Na, ist jetzt nicht so, als dass wir das brauchen, ich reboot noch mal schnell, dass der auch
das ganze Farbschema und so wieder lädt, dann wollen wir mal gucken, also folgendes, wenn
wir, hallo, wenn wir Chrome kompilieren wollen, ich habe das vor Urzeiten mal versucht, ich
glaube, ich habe es nie richtig hingekriegt, was man dazu braucht, ist viel RAM, viel Festplattenplatz
und viel CPUs, also man kompiliert mittlerweile ein Betriebssystem schneller als Chrome,
ist kein Witz, der aktuelle Linux-Körner, aber wohlgemerkt, da ist es auch nicht allzu
viel dabei, im Vergleich zu einem vollwertigen Desktop-System, der aktuelle Linux-Körner,
den kompilierst du so in, keine Ahnung, 4 Minuten, ungefähr sind wir da umgepeilt,
4-5 Minuten und Chrome braucht wahrscheinlich eine ganze ganze ganze Ecke länger, also wir
haben hier CPU-Kerne 4 von 6 verfügbaren, mehr kann ich der VM erstmal nicht geben,
wir haben 60 GB RAM in der VM, nochmal 16 GB Swap, das sollte eigentlich reichen, ja
die Musik ist nicht poggers, also mehr geht nicht, so und Festplattenplatz haben wir
auch 125G, also wenn das nicht reicht, wenn das nicht reicht zu kompilieren für Chrome,
das weiß ich auch nicht, aber das komplizierte an Chrome kompilieren ist, den ganzen Scheiß
zu installieren und das, ich meine damit wirklich den ganzen Scheiß, das braucht so viel Abhängigkeiten,
kann mich noch dran erinnern, dass das ein riesen Akt war, das alles installiert zu kriegen,
die Playlist kann sich wieder eindeutig nicht entscheiden, wie laut sie sein will, so und
zum Thema Grafikkarten übertakten, wollte ich nur noch mal kurz was zeigen, wie weit
es bei mir funktioniert hat, Afterburner, was ist das denn, warum, ich dachte der installiert
den global, ok dann kann ich es euch doch nicht zeigen, aus welchem Grund kompilierst
du selbst, steht doch sogar schon in der Überschrift, aus 2 Gründen, also erstens will ich es überhaupt
mal machen, also jetzt mit einem neueren Chrome und zweitens, habe ich mir gedacht vielleicht
brauche ich ja irgendwann mal für Hardware Video Beschleunigung irgendwelche Custom Patches
und dann ist es nicht schlechtes zu wissen, ansonsten habe ich nichts weiter mit der selbst
kompilierten Chrome Version vor, ich will einfach nur gucken, wie das funktioniert,
how to compile Chrome, also Chromium, Chrome selbst geht ja nicht, vor Windows hier, ihr
müsst euch mal die Anleitung durchlesen, die ist absolut schon Big Brain, hier, 3000
Sachen machen, dass du Chrome selbst kompilieren kannst, für Linux, ja ja ja, wie gesagt
wir haben 4 CPU Kerne, 16G Rahmen, 16G Swap, 120G Festplatte, das reicht, wieso kombiniert
man eigentlich manche Sachen unter Linux, gibt es mehrere Gründe, erster Grund ist,
dass es vielleicht, dass die Software die du verwenden willst nicht gibt, für deine
Distribution fertig, das ist die erste Variante, die nahelinkste Variante, zweite Variante
ist, dass die Software zu alt ist, die bei deiner Distribution dabei ist, dritte Variante
ist, es gibt keine Custom Repos, wo die Software drin ist, die du haben willst, das ist halt
auch so nicht verfügbar, oder aber es gibt was und du möchtest eigene Patches haben,
die halt in der Software, die es vorkompiliert, Prebuild gibt, für deine Distribution nicht
dabei ist, also es gibt ein paar Gründe, zum Beispiel, was in der Vergangenheit recht
oft selbst gemacht wurde, war auf dem Raspberry Pi, Open, aber wie hieß das, OpenCL, ne wie
hieß das, Open, dieses Video Ding, Open, ne, Video, Open, CV, das da, OpenCV für
den Raspberry Pi, hat man in der Vergangenheit relativ oft selbst kompiliert, FFmpeg auch,
allerdings sind mittlerweile schon aktualisierte Versionen dabei, dass man das nicht mehr
machen muss, ja, die Musik ist voll hektisch jetzt, ja das ist auch hier, Kirby Musik,
ich muss mal den Monitor weg machen, ja, es wundert mich jetzt, dass der alles schon geupdatet
hat, vor allem frage ich mich, was der für Schmerzen hat, warum man den anderen Kram
nicht updaten kann, updaten wir erstmal den Prompt, das kann ja nicht schaden, ach so
Moment, Update, Packages, was, was, was der ist, er muss glaub ich noch eingehen, was der
alle macht, kann man die Option immer nicht merken von dem Kram, Bitcoins Brrrr, was,
nicht Brrrr, 2 Euro Dankeschön, excellent, Chat IQ steigt, also 4, 3, 1, S, warum kann
ich dem nicht sagen, dass er ein Paket auslassen soll, ja ich kann das über die User Repo kompilieren,
das ist keine Frage, kann ich machen, aber das kann ja jeder, wir brauchen übrigens
ein CAC, CAC WWW Emote unbedingt, das passt so gut zu Browser, warum kann ich dem nicht
sagen, dass er das, ah Packages to exclude, 2, Packages to clean build, all, ah yes, jetzt
macht er es auch, 1 Cent, excellent Chat hier, heute geht es ab, ich lasse den mal gerade
aktualisieren, inzwischenzeit gucken wir uns schonmal an, wie das funktioniert überhaupt
mit Chrome bilden, ich muss übrigens gerade mal meinen Bildschirm umschalten, oh warum
spackt das rum, wenn ich den Bildschirm umschalte mit Sound, ah weil der Bildschirm ja per USB
dran ist, ja der Bildschirm ist ja per USB dran und der Bildschirm meldet sich irgendwie
auch per Soundkarte an, total hängen geblieben, guckt euch das mal an, der Bildschirm meldet
sich irgendwie per USB Audio Interface an, also was muss man machen, Instruction for Google
Employees, ne das ist für die wirklich big brain, Leute, also System Requirements, 64
Intel Maschinen with at least 8GB of RAM, 16GB is highly recommended, dann das passt, haben
wir, 16G, 100G of Free Disk Space, ist euer Ernst, ihr braucht wirklich 100G, 100G, das
glaube ich nicht, Fake News, Git und Python V2, das ist ja uralt, Python V2 ist da glaube
ich gar nicht drauf, warum, warum, warum Hund, ähm, Schwachsinn was erzähl ich, ähm, warum
man so viel RAM braucht verstehe ich auch nicht, ist ja wurscht, wir können bestimmt
irgendwas löschen, guck mal, warum hab ich da überhaupt 42G drauf, übrigens wer das
hier unter Windows kennt, hier dieses Win, das kennt ihr ja unter Windows, oder ich denke
mal die meisten kennen das wo man sich die Plattenauslastung errechnen lassen kann,
so, ähm, unter Linux kann man was ähnliches machen, zwar damit, ist vielleicht nicht
ganz so hübsch, aber reicht mir, ja man kanns auch mit Do selbst machen, aber ich finde
das so viel schicker, so, Swap, ah, ich hab nur ein Swapfile von 16G, deswegen ist das
auch so voll, ja dann, ich kann den Chat, ich kann den Swapfile ausschalten, aber wir
probierens einfach mal, Downloads, guck mal hier, Respian Images, können wir, alle ganze
Shit können wir runter schmeißen, bäm, bäm, zack, siehste und schon haben wir wieder Platz,
Local Cache, Vmware Track and Drop, Respian, bäm, bäm, siehste und schon haben wir wieder
fast 100Mb, äh, 100G Platz, das reicht, wunderbar, genug, mkdir, Build, oder war mkdir, Crow,
ne, mkdir, Keg, W, W, W, reicht save mich, ey wenn nicht dann kann mich google mal, also
mit was muss man da anfangen, Maust Development ist dann on Ubuntu 16.04,
Microsoft Teams oder Slack, ich hab keine großartige Erfahrung mit Slack, nur mit Teams,
Teams ist ok, auch wenn es mir an vielen Bereichen auf den Sack geht, aber das ist so ein typisches
Microsoft Produkt, so 80% ist ok und die anderen 20% nerven halt, wie, wie Sau, ah wir haben
ja 32G RAM mit Swap, also RAM ausgehen will uns wahrscheinlich nicht, der Golem Beitrag
zu Teams den kenn ich nicht, also jetzt müssen wir erstmal Depot Tools installieren, was
auch immer Depot Tools ist, gibt's das vielleicht hier, Depot Tools, ah guck mal, schon fix
und fertig für uns gebaut, exellent, dann müssen wir das gar nicht mehr selbst machen,
so mag ich das, komm mal, der zählt auf Python 2 als Abhängigkeit, so ist gut, beim Bilden
lesen, ja beim Bilden können wir viel uns angucken, hab ich mir übrigens schon vorbestellt,
wollte ich eigentlich heute Abend mal ne Runde spielen, das TNT Remastered, weil Alarmstufe
rot, beste, kann das sein, dass ich hier kein Adblock drauf hab, uBlock Origin, muss gleich
installiert werden, Firefox, jawoll, Patrick Alarm, was los, so zack, guck und schon ist
die Wärmung weg, exellent, C&C Stream, die Story ist, also die Alarmstufe rot, ist so
extrem cringe, ja das wundert mich nicht, ja aber der muss auch zu allem seinen Saft
vielleicht auch, seinen Senf abgeben, meinst du den Artikel hier, ja den können wir später
mal gucken, so wir haben installiert, ok OpTools, hier Dingstools, DepotTools sind installiert,
get the code, mkdir Chromium, ok, ok wir machen das, ok der möchte im Heimatverzeichnis gebildet
werden, alles klar, ok, run FetchTool, FetchNoHooksChromium, exellent, ist schon mal gut, dass es nicht
funktioniert, super, lull, angeblich, angeblich ist der DigiClient dabei, gibts nicht, leht
ihr nicht im Pass, ich frag mich nur warum das nicht im Pass ist, normalerweise machen
das die Pakete, dann kann ichs auch installieren und selbst in Pass hauen, dann kann ichs auch
selbst machen, ok dann müssen wir doch nochmal oben anfangen, also clone, DepotTools, exellent,
so Python 2 müssen wir installieren, 3, ja, gut, add DepotTools to your pass, ja machen
wir, machen wir, zwar mein DepotTools liegt hier, da, pass, bla bla, da liegt mein DepotTools,
ok, DigiClient, geht das jetzt, ne, was hab ich verkehrt gemacht, hab ich irgendwo vertippt,
muss doch eigentlich funktionieren, so, kann das sein, ich wollte gerade sagen kann das
sein, dass das nicht im Fahrt geht, aber das wäre doch echt doof, äh, wow, home, home,
max, ah jetzt gehts, alles gut, so, die Playlist kann sich echt nicht entscheiden wie laut
und leise es sein mag, gut, also jetzt haben wir den Kram installiert, jetzt können wir
weitermachen, dann packen wir das gerade mal nochmal, falls wir die Shell zu machen, packen
wir das nochmal in meine, ok, also jetzt können wir weitermachen, wir haben das Ding, jetzt
können wir Fetch, Fetch No Hooks Chromium, jetzt läuft das nämlich auch, bin mal echt
gespannt wie lange das dauert, das dauert bestimmt locker ne Stunde, wenn nicht noch
viel länger, und mal gucken ob Platte ausreicht, und ob alles ausreicht, nebenbei, nebenbei
machen wir natürlich den Hardtop auf, wir müssen ja kürzer gucken was abgeht, äh,
den D-Stat machen wir auf, was, nee, seht, gleich mal hinterherhauen, D-Stat auf, dass
wir alle aussehen, und, nein, äh, und, und im Free, ah, so, jetzt haben wir die Übersicht,
oh, was alle für Schmerzen, Running Client on Python 3, du sollst den nicht an Python
3 run, ok, nochmal, Chromium, CD, Chromium, Fetch, Fetch, warum, warum, warum ist das
in Python 3, was ist das für ein Schwachs, ah, ich weiß warum, oh nee, oh das sackt
ja richtig, ich weiß woran es liegt, ich zeig euch auch gleich woran es liegt, weil,
ähm, ja, genau, weil unter Arch, beziehungsweise Macharo Python 3 Standard ist, und die, die
Standard umgebogen haben, also, ah ok, das muss ich doch machen, aber anscheinend geht
es auch mit Python 3, guck mal, Pain's Champ, richtig Pain's Champ, aber guck mal, es funktioniert
anscheinend auch mit Python 3, der klont jetzt erstmal, das braucht jetzt 5 Stunden
wahrscheinlich, expect the command to take 30 minutes, äh, Moment, no history, exellent,
jetzt wollen wir haben, no history, no history, naja, wir machen hier mal alles weg, trash
not found, ziemlich viel Zeug nicht installiert, so, löschen, trash empty, machen wir das
ganze noch mal, fetch, no history, dann gehts schneller, hoffen wir mal, wie, äh,
ich hab doch legit das gemacht, was da stand, hä, oh sag bloß, das hat sich jetzt irgendwie
was, was gemerkt, oh, meine Güte, was ist denn das, ok, wie löscht man das jetzt,
config, gclient, hier, das löschen wir alles, das löschen wir alles, das bestimmt alles
failed, probieren wirs noch mal, weil hier ist sonst nichts mehr drin, fetch, no history,
ah, ah, guck mal, das sieht besser aus, er hängt jetzt schön, ah, exellent, gut, jetzt
müssen wir kurz warten, bis der das gesamte git repo von chromium geklont hat, ich glaub,
es wird ein bisschen dauern, so, was soll ich mir angucken, den teams artikel von golem,
amazon setzt auf slack, ok, ihr wisst, was als nächstes passiert, oder, als nächstes
kauft amazon slack, das ist der falsche, ok, was ist der richtige, auf der startseite ist
nichts mehr da, was ich bei golem immer bemerkenswert finde, die schaffen es, dass man nicht den
knopf findet, wie man sich vergangene news richtig anzeigen lassen kann, das ist richtig
low brain, ich finde das immer nicht, ja, weitere news im ticker, das da, zusammenarbeit
zwischen teams, ok, perfektes werkzeug, um effizienz zu vernichten, oh, das scheint mir
einer zu sein, der teams nicht mag, das scheint mir einer zu sein, der teams nicht mag, ich
muss sagen, ich persönlich finde teams ganz ok, es gibt wenig software, die mir eigentlich
so egal ist, also, die meisten sachen finde ich entweder eher gut oder eher schlecht,
aber teams ist mir eigentlich vollkommen egal, weil ich benutze teams privat nicht und ich
habe auch nicht mal ansatzweise vor teams privat zu benutzen, allerdings verwenden wir
teams auf der arbeit und es nervt mich bei weitem nicht so wie andere, wie andere programme,
also wenn ich mir überlege, was mich am meisten nervt auf der arbeit an software, dann war
es früher lotus notes, falls das noch jemand kennt, ja, excellent software hier, da ist
lotus notes, lotus notes, monkaS, das war früher das schlimmste, das ist die schlimmste,
eine der schlimmsten soft, ja, genau so sah der kack aus, genau so sah dieser shit aus,
wirklich das allerschlimmste, also das größte Drecksprogramm aller Zeiten, danach war es,
ich wollte es gerade sagen, flo96 und skype for business, ging mir auch extrem auf den
keks, beides haben wir nicht mehr, übrigens guckt euch mal an, welch Augenweide, welch
Augenweide dieser kachel Bildschirme, bevor windows kachel erfunden hat, ist eigentlich
noch, gibt es eigentlich noch Dreckstool.de, enter, lotus notes führt, jawoll, die seite
sieht nicht nur aus wie von 1999, der ist glaube ich auch von 1999, also skype for business
ging mir auch extrem auf den kack, lotus notes ging mir extrem auf den kack, äh auf den
kack, ja auf den kack ging es mir tatsächlich, ich wollte eigentlich sagen auf den sack,
aber auf den kack trifft es glaube ich fast besser, so und windows nervt mich permanent
eigentlich, wenn ich unter windows was machen muss und ansonsten, unsere zeiterfassung geht
mir noch auf den keks, weil die geht nur im internet explorer richtig, ist jetzt kein
scherz, die ist optimiert, steht sogar noch drinnen, die ist optimiert für microsoft
internet explorer, und was hatten wir ansonsten noch schönes, was mir auf den keks gegangen
ist, das adlessian zeug geht mir manchmal auf den keks, weil es extrem umständlich
ist an vielen stellen, also gerade mal confluence, dass es keinen gescheiten marktdown editor
bis heute hat, 2020 ja, wow was macht denn das im hintergrund, es hat 17 gigabyte schon
heruntergeladen, monkaS, ähm und ansonsten ist die software die wir auf der arbeit haben
eigentlich zum größten teil ganz ok, ja confluence suche ist auch eklig, confluence suche kannst
du komplett vergessen, während es downloadet noch eine lustige
geschichte von der arbeit, was letztens wieder gewesen ist, also so als beispiel, dass man
manchmal die arschkarte hat, wenn man freiwillig was macht, und zwar nachdem es bei uns nicht
so einfach ist auf den ersten blick rauszubekommen, wo welches system steht bzw. zu was welches
system gehört, weil wir ein absolut wirres namensschema für server und systeme und services
sind, habe ich mal irgendwann bin ich auf die glorreiche idee gekommen, habe gesagt
hey wir machen eine web, wir machen einen confluence plugin, so plug in den anführungszeichen,
ja doch ein halbes confluence plugin, und das zieht sich aus unterschiedlichen quellen
die information, welche host es gibt, und rennt da draußen übersicht wenn man die seite
aufmacht, so das habe ich mal gebaut vor 3 jahren oder so, ist schon eine ganze weile
her, und das war, das hat keiner wirklich beauftragt in dem sinn, sondern ich habe es einfach gemacht
weil es mir auf den keks ging, das hat sich dann auch halbwegs etabliert, da haben immer
mehr leute reingeguckt, aber das war nie was offizielles, es war nie was offizielles, so
und jetzt haben die letztens, haben die irgendwie den confluence server umgestellt, und auf
einmal ruft mich irgendjemand vom, wie heißt, vom notfallmanagement an, ich wusste gar
nicht, dass wir sowas haben, naja, und erzählt mir dann irgendwie, oh ja die hostliste im
confluence wäre kaputt, und ich wäre notfallrelevant, ich hab mir gesagt, was, das ist was, was
ich in nacht und nebel aktion zusammengestrickt habe, das ist nichts offizielles, und kann
morgen schon wieder weg sein, wie kann das notfallrelevant sein, ja ob ich nicht mal gucken
könnte, dass ich es wieder zum laufen kriege, also manchmal hast du echt voll die arschkarte
wenn du freiwillig irgendwas machst, das ist richtig pepega, total hängen geblieben,
ja, und ich hab halt gesagt, ich will das nicht weiter supporten, was soll das, warum
steht das irgendwo drin, warum ist das notfallrelevant, ne inoffizielle confluence seite, die ich
irgendwann mal erstellt hab, also beziehungsweise ne generierte confluence seite, die ich irgendwann
mal erstellt hab, nie irgendwo bekannt gemacht, sonst wie, einfach nur über hören sagen
weiter verbreiten, wie kann die notfallrelevant sein, und dazu gibt es eigentlich schon die
beste antwort, nichts mehr freiwillig machen, oh wir sind fertig, guck mal, er hat geklont,
so wie gehts denn weiter, ok jetzt müssen wir, if you don't want full, if you already
installed build dependencies, was, weiß nicht ob ich build dependencies in zähl hab, ok,
when fetch is complete switch to source directory, exellent da sind wir drin, ich muss mal kurz
gucken wie groß das eigentlich ist, 16 gigabyte Leute, 16 gigabyte source files, das ist,
das ist massive, haha, patrick das wärs wirklich, ok, jetzt müssen wir build install build
depths, ne oder, das ist jetzt nicht euer ernst, google, ach google, könnt ihr den check nicht
am anfang einbauen, könnt ihr den check nicht am anfang machen, jebaited, aber richtig
jebaited hier, aber nichtsdestotrotz, man kann das garantiert hier bilden, das geht bestimmt,
wir machen einfach den check raus, ach guck mal options, enable, minus minus unsupported,
guck mal da, exellent, ich war mal kurz in snapshot, man weiß ja nie, was, ok, warum
muss ich das also, oh nein, das will auch mit debian zeug machen, ok, fuck, das wird
im leben nix, ubuntu container erstellen, das könnte man, das könnte man wahrscheinlich
echt machen, oh nee, jetzt wirds aber ekelig, ich guck mal was, chromium, was hat denn das
source build aus dem package manager für, ich muss mal gucken was die für dependencies
haben, da kann ich mir das abschauen, snapshot, dev, neun, neun, neun, du scheiße, wir können
das in ubuntu container erstellen, ja, können wir machen, boah, was hat denn das überhaupt
für dependencies, was braucht das denn eigentlich für das halbe internet oder wie, dpkg, 32
schmidt libraries, bin, oh, ach du scheiße, ruby auch noch, was ist das für ein komischer
buildprozess, die brauchen ruby, die brauchen, ok google, oh nee, ich darf nicht ok google
sagen, sonst geht bei euch alles an, die brauchen svn, ok klar, monkaS, ok wir installieren
uns in container, ok wir installieren uns in container, das heißt wir löschen den
kram wieder, wir löschen wieder alles, wir löschen wieder alles, komm mal hier, das
braucht schon 3 stunden zu löschen, wir machen uns in container, nee wir machen kein
spawn, wir machen lxd oder vielleicht auch irgendeinen docker, aber lxd ist in dem fall
sogar einfacher, heck und hier den kram, alles weg, alles weg, was ein kack, ich fasse
es nicht, was man da alles für müll installieren muss, ok das können wir dazu machen, das
brauchen wir auf dem system eh nicht, also habe ich denn in lxd, haben wir einen docker,
nee wir haben nix installiert, haben wir einen snap, irgendwas container mäßig ist installiert,
ok, gibt es das hier überhaupt zum installieren, nein, alter wie, ich weiß wir können uns
auch ne ubuntu vm machen, aber warum, ja, lxd init sudo, nicht gestartet, ok, system
ttl start, ja ist ja gut, ich bin nicht in der, would you like to use lxd, klar nee
no, would you like to configure, yes, name of storage pool default, directory, no, would
you like to create a new local network bridge, no, would you like to configure the existing
bridge, yes, und zwar mein interface heißt, mein netzwerk ens 33, excellent, would you
like to available over network, no, yes, was auch immer, no, ok und wie ging das lxd, lxd
launch ubuntu 20.04, nee was haben die geschrieben was unterstützt wird, leute wisst ihr noch
fast was sie geschrieben haben, 1804, 18 aber mal 1804, alles als root, scheiß drauf, alles
als root, 16 bis 20 war das ok, naja, starting advanced monster, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
so heißt meine, meine container, advanced monster, ok, da ist es, oh, state error, oh
warum geht das jetzt schon wieder nicht, ich kriege anfälle, das will nicht, das will
nicht, dass wir heute was machen, stoppt, start advanced monster, das mag nicht, leute,
das ist kaputt, möchte nicht, dass wir container erstellen, guckt, error, warum, meine Güte,
dass sowas auch nicht einfach mal funktionieren kann, ne, doch ätzend, also, dann müssen
das jetzt auch noch irgendwie die messages, ich sehe nichts, ich sehe nichts schlimmes,
ich sehe nichts schlimmes, na wobei, was hat er für schmerzen, gibt es keine lxd logs,
ich dachte, der schreibt es in keinen log rein, macht er normalerweise auch, aber da
steht nichts drin, ok, probieren wir es noch mal, wie ist das Ding, advanced monster, start
advanced, advanced monster, ne, äh, warte mal, ist xe, war das unten, na, ja, echt,
error, fail to stop device eth0, was, ich habe ja auch kein eth0, hä, will container
starten, äh, fail to stop device eth0, ist ja klar, was haben wir unten, unable to set
cpu set, error, fail to set cgroup cpu set, ok, das ist irgendeine se-linux-geschichte
oder so, kann das sein, ist das irgendeine se-linux-geschichte, na, ja, ok, ok, ok,
stimmt, ich hab gar kein se-linux drauf, ne, ja, dann dürfte es eigentlich auch kein
problem geben, dann initialisieren wir das einfach noch mal neu, äh, would you like,
no, und dann sagen wir jetzt, er soll ein bridge-interface anlegen, äh, configure new
storage pool, yes, default, already exist plus, default 2, 23, dear, no, would you like, yes,
ja, jawoll, excellent, would you like lxd to be available, no, yes, yes, device validation
fail-etica, der hat irgendeinen shit eingestellt, der hat irgendeinen Mist eingestellt, der
hat irgendeinen Mist eingestellt, ok, lx, edit, profile, oder wie ging das, edit, was,
oh, wisst ihr was, dafür haben wir snapshots, reset, yes, ich installiere das einfach noch
mal neu und mach den assistent, wenn wir schon in der vm sind, dann können wir es auch uns
einfacher machen, außerdem ist jetzt der snapshot brauche ich nicht mehr so viel speicherplatz,
musik ist richtig nice heute in der playlist, ja, Ubuntu vm kann jeder machen, und wahrscheinlich
geht es dann im container nicht aus irgendwelchen gründen, warte uns mal ab, äh, gut, achso,
wir waren, ok, wir müssen den kram noch alles löschen, aber noch gar nicht gemacht, na,
gut, dann löschen wir die chrome geschichten schnell wieder, chrome löschen, keqw löschen,
oh, und was hatten wir sonst noch, rm, isntcrap und das wars dann auch, trash, weg damit,
das ist trash, trash, trash mobs, so, cannot remove, doch kannst du, glaub mir, du kannst,
glaub mir, es funktioniert, äh, keqw, du kannst es löschen, ich weiß, dass du es löschen
kannst, sudo, baam, alles weg, warum ging das vorher und jetzt nicht, ok, dann machen
wir jetzt den snapshot weg, wir machen jetzt trick 17 snapshot manager, wir löschen den
snapshot und machen dann den neuen snapshot, f0-musik, ist das, war das nicht gerade, war
doch gerade, oder, wir hatten doch eben gerade erst f0-musik, ok, jetzt haben wir einen
snapshot, jawoll, oh, das awoken icon-team, das ist für alle, die hier bei, die immer
ganz besonders wach sind, so, 9, ne, wir machen den ganzen kram jetzt also gut, weil, warum
auch nicht, init, achso, systemctl start, no, yes, default, dear, no, local bridge, yes,
yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, ok, lxc-launch ubuntu 18.4, mal gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert,
ja, ich dachte auch erst, dass es ein Fehler ist im Container, aber, aha, aber nachdem
der eben geschrieben hat, dass er die config nicht editieren kann, weil eth0 drin steht,
warum ist das eigentlich gerade alles gegen mich und will nicht, dass ich was mache, was,
what the fuck, payload gentle, gentle say tier, also das ist der Name von der vm, remapping,
was willst du von mir, alter, no space left on device, what, die Fehlermeldung ergeben
überhaupt keinen Sinn, hä, no space left on device, docker ist einfach so viel einfacher,
in dem Fall eigentlich nicht, lxc ist insofern besser, weil du dort einen Container kriegst,
der mehr wie eine vm ist und ich könnte wetten, dass docker auch rumspackt, wenn lxc rumspackt,
wir können es ja mal ausprobieren, wir können es ja mal ausprobieren, ich resette noch mal
den snapshot, wir sind ja genau an der Stelle, das heißt, wir müssen jetzt nichts mehr zusätzlich
machen, ich resette den snapshot, wir installieren docker, pass mal auf, ich könnte wetten,
dass das auch Probleme hat, aber, wie gesagt, docker bringen uns auch nicht so viele, also
mit lxc ist das viel einfacher, wenn es läuft, ja, sowas zu machen, weil es viel mehr wie
eine vm ist, ich hab noch ne Idee, ich hab noch ne Idee, wir installieren jetzt lxd nicht
direkt, wir installieren uns jetzt snap und installieren lxd über snap, da kann ja nix
mal schief gehen, wenn wir eine container-technologie verwenden, um container-technologien zu installieren,
snap, lxd, gibt es das überhaupt noch, ja, exzellent, perfekt, dann machen wir das so,
snap, vielleicht hätte ich einfach mal rebooten sollen, aber snap musst du in flatpak installieren,
ja, exzellent, so machen wir das, snap, start, so, snap, list, snap, install, lxd, ey, wenn
das jetzt funktioniert, dann lag ich mich kaputt, ja, okay, aber das ist doch langweilig, ich
will doch alles selbst installieren, wir hätten in der Zwischenzeit schon längst so ein Ubuntu
vm installieren, wisst ihr das, aber das kann ja nicht sein, was soll das hier, achso, ja,
wir müssen erstmal init machen, ja, lxd init, yes, yes, yes, ich glaube wir können bei
allem yes sagen, hier müssen wir dir sagen, ey, wenn das jetzt funktioniert, dann lag
ich mich echt kaputt, das wäre mega fail, wenn das funktionieren würde, also wenn das
jetzt funktionieren würde, um den Umweg wäre ich komplett hängen geblieben, Pausechamp,
und, und, und, okay, okay, easy, also Containertechnologie über Containertechnologie installiert verfunktioniert
besser als Containertechnologie direkt über den Paketmanager installiert, Verfahrung
auch immer, lxc, exec, amusing mac, immer bash, jawoll, jetzt haben wir unser Ubuntu
Container, da freut sich Nelson Mandela, Upgrade, Upgrade, wir hätten ja auch Chrome auf dem
Raspberry Pi kompilieren können, da hätten wir ein richtiges Debian gehabt, dann hätten
wir uns aber morgen wieder gesehen ungefähr, jetzt weiß ich wozu man den neuen Raspberry
Pi braucht mit 8GB RAM, endlich habe ich einen Anwendungszweck für, jetzt weiß ich wofür
man den braucht, jetzt ergibt es Sinn, guck mal, Leute, die bringen doch nicht ohne Grund
einen 8GB Raspberry Pi und die Möglichkeit von SSD zu booten raus, wenn die nicht wollen,
dass man damit Chrome kompiliert, das wird es sein Leute, wir haben es exposed, durchschaut
haben wir sie, ja es gibt einen neuen Raspberry Pi mit 8GB, wo ich halt keine Ahnung hab wofür
der da ist, so, also jetzt können wir weitermachen beim Chrome Build, weil wir haben jetzt ja
hier unseren Container, wo alles drauf ist, so, alles da, Free, 816G, Platte, mehr als
genug, ok, also weiter gehts, also dann machen wir den ganzen Kram, nochmal den wir gerade
gemacht haben, die Potools klonen, ja, könnte man machen mit dem 8GB Raspberry Pi, tatsächlich,
Enigma Code, das hört sich aber nicht gut an, Monarch S, ok, so, und jetzt muss man
was machen, den Pass zu den Tools angeben, genau, der Pass ist, natürlich machen wir
alles als Root, ey wisst ihr was, gleich kommt ne Meldung, Chromium sollte nicht als Root
gebaut werden, dann kotze ich, was, halt's Maul, ist mir egal ob das sad ist, so, ok
jetzt müssen wir das ganze Fetchen, Fetch Chromium mit, allerdings ohne History, da braucht
es nämlich nur 5 Minuten, ja, no History, stimmt wir können einfach nen User hinzufügen,
ja das könnte man machen, aber trotzdem ey, sie sollen mich nicht so gängeln, sie sollen
mich einfach Chrom kompilieren lassen, ok, da sollte den Kram jetzt auschecken, wir wissen
dass die Internetverbindung geht, wir haben ja gerade Paket Updates gemacht, ja, ok, gut,
da können wir uns doch jetzt noch mal den Golem Artikel angucken, ja, also das liest
sich wie ein Artikel von jemand, der echt keinen Bock auf den Kram hat, perfektes Werkzeug
um Effizienz zu vernichten, ok, ja jetzt übertreibt er aber ein bisschen, ich will das gar nicht
lesen ehrlich gesagt, Herstellervideo, das gucken wir uns jetzt an, das ist so richtig
schön happy und glücklich alle wieder in diesem Video wahrscheinlich, aber ich hab
gar keinen Sound hier merke ich gerade, weil vor allem, das ist bestimmt wieder so happy
bis zum Fremdschämen happy, ja genau, die Schulkinder in Afrika, die brauchen natürlich
unbedingt Microsoft Teams, was würden die nur ohne Microsoft Teams machen, in welcher
Auflösung ist das eigentlich, das A hier, HD, das soll HD gewesen sein, das sieht aus
wie YouTube 480p, HD, zu Loll, Teams sind liquid, ah ok, ich mach kurz einen Tick lauter,
warte mal, verstehts wahrscheinlich gerade richtig, ja, das ist so die Wunschvorstellung,
dass die Formel 1 Teams Teams verwenden, ah stimmt, und natürlich, wie wir hier alle
sehen, der Human Way schlechthin ist natürlich Excel Tabellen und außerdem ist das ein Light
up, das geht ja gar nicht, aber der Human Way laut Microsoft ist Excel Tabellen, was
auch sonst, was ist humaner als Excel Tabellen, exakt so siehts auch immer aus, wenn Leute
bei uns einen Call machen, genau so, ganz genau so, ja, so und nicht anders, alle haben
so schön ausgeblurten Background, das heißt die haben schonmal ne ordentliche Kamera dran
oder machen so ein Smartphone, alle im Hintergrund schön aufgeräumt und wunderbar, vom Hintergrund
auch sehr stylish, alles eingerichtet, alle gute Kameras, keiner der irgendwie großartig
rauscht, genauso, so sieht die Realität aus bei Team Calls, was ist Power BI, oder ist
es vielleicht sogar Power B, das geht ja nicht, was mit allen anderen, oh, was ist das, was
ist das, oh, Leute wisst ihr an was ich da grad denken muss, wo ich das sehe, also ich
muss, ich muss jetzt echt da dran denken, was es hier auf Steam gibt, irgendwie hat mich
das grad erinnert, okay, der Sinn von Chat ist unter anderem, dass man auch chatten kann,
solange der andere nicht da ist, weil er sieht es dann, egal, also, ja, gut, Microsoft, einmal,
und wenns Microsoft nicht anpreist, dann wer preist denn bitteschön sonst an, ja, Microsoft
Teams, Teams, sorry, Teams, kann man aber nicht sagen, die hat einen indischen Akzent
und der Ober-Microsoft-CEO ist ja auch ein Inder, also die sind, seitdem muss man echt
sagen, seitdem die den haben, ist Microsoft sowas von, wie nennt man es so, international
aufgestellt, irgendwie, finde ich sogar noch viel mehr gefühlt als früher, der Google-Chef
ist auch aus, stimmt, der Google-Chef ist auch Inder, ja, stimmt, seitdem Google ja
jetzt nur noch Teil von ABC ist, ja, multikulturell, genau, divers, wie man neuerdings so schön
sagt, ja, also das muss ich mir jetzt nicht angucken, ehrlich gesagt, der Rant hat halt
ein bisschen über Teams und damit hat er wahrscheinlich auch bedingt Recht, aber ich
muss sagen, mir ist Teams vollkommen egal, wir verwenden es auf der Arbeit, es gibt ein
paar Sachen, die nerven mich, groß und ganz geht Teams in Ordnung, oh komm mal, wir sind
gleich fertig mit sunken, exellent, ansonsten das beste bei Microsoft Teams ist ja natürlich
immer noch das hier, der Meme Generator, also wer Teams verwendet und es noch nicht gesehen
hat, Microsoft hat einen Meme Generator eingebaut, irgendwo hier unter Custom, unter Sticker,
also das ist die allerwichtigste Option in diesem Chatfenster, der Meme Generator, aber
leider gehen keine Custom Builder, Custom Builder gehen nur hier über Custom Builder
hochladen, das ist bei uns aus, was das kann man ausschalten, der Meme Generator ist mit
das beste an Teams, an Deams, sorry, an Deams, das brauchen wir, ohne geht das nicht, ja,
was wollte ich jetzt gerade noch sagen, Teams, Teams, genau, irgendjemand im Chat hat nämlich
gesagt Teams steht und fällt mit den Usern, das stimmt, aber wenn es bei uns klappt, hat
es das Potential bei allen zu klappen, wir sind sehr gemischt und bei uns ist der Altersdurchschnitt
auch eine ganze Ecke älter als ich, glaube der Altersdurchschnitt ist bei 45 oder so,
der Altersdurchschnitt ist riesengroß und hoch bei uns, richtig viele Boomer am Start,
richtig massiv viele und wenn das bei uns mit Teams klappt, dann hat es das Potential
überall zu klappen, es hat auch jemand gefragt, ob man nicht lieber Discord anstatt Teams
verwenden sollte, wenn es nach mir geht schon, natürlich ist bei Discord wahrscheinlich
der Datenschutz das Problem, wo sich viele daran stören werden, hi wie gehts, ich warte
dass das Chrome Repo runtergeladen ist, Microsoft Teams, fertig, sehr schön, ok, Chromiumens
kompilieren, weiter gehts, Bild, Source, CD, Source, Bild, Install, Dependencies, exzellent,
los gehts, jetzt funktionierts auch hier unter, was, Adwoblos, was ist, ah Musik, stimmt,
ok, Abt Install Python 2, einfach nur so, Abt Install Qt, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher,
ob es ein Programm gibt, was Qt heißt bestimmt, nein, gibt es nicht, das ist aber eine Lücke,
das ist aber echt eine Lücke, by the way, warum installiert es nicht Python, wenn es
das braucht, wow, das installiert es echt das halbe Internet, die meinen das ernst mit
100 Gigabyte, ich würde Discord nicht unbedingt als Slackfork bezeichnen, ich glaube das gab
sogar früher und von den Funktionen her finde ich Discord ist eigentlich das beste, ja
vielleicht, ich teile die Datenschutzbedenken die viele haben bei Discord, weil du hast
halt komplett egal was du machst geht bei denen über die Reserve, aber ok, so der installiert
jetzt erstmal Abhängigkeiten, das kann man in der Zwischenzeit machen, Zoom legt eh keinen
Wert auf Security, ja das stimmt, allerdings muss ich sagen ich finde es auch nicht gut
dass Zoom so extrem getrashed wird dafür, Zoom war ein richtig mini Teil, Programm,
Unternehmen, was auch immer, bevor das explodiert ist dann Corona und Zoom sagt das ja auch,
also Zoom macht ja gar nicht auch wahnsinnig secure, die fangen ja jetzt erst an, also
man muss Zoom gar nicht so sehr dafür trash-talken, dass das halt nicht sicher ist, ich meine
man kann alles dafür trash-talken, dass es nicht sicher ist, aber wenigstens tun sie
nicht so, bei Zoom weiß man es wenigstens, das ist nicht wie Microsoft die sagen ah ja
nur alles in deinem Interesse und wir sammeln nix und dann kommt raus ah doch sammeln wir
doch, huge Audio Qualität, ja aber die Audio Qualität war richtig mies, hat Zoom nicht
irgendeine Krypto oder VPN Firma gekauft, weiß ich nicht, kann sein, glaube ich aber nicht,
aber ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung, echt Zoom hat gesagt sie verschlüsseln und haben
nicht verschlüsseln, ja ok das ist fail, dann werden sie zurecht getrashedalken, dann hab
ich nix gesagt, ja wie geht das, igitt, was ist das für ein Hintergrundfarbe, das
haben wir ja schon aus und trotzdem darf Teamsters, ach man Windows, unter Linux wäre das nicht
passiert, unter Linux hätten wir aber ein ganz anderes Problem, dass die ganzen Sachen
nicht laufen würden, das Nox 270, ja du weißt, wen ich meine, das habe ich mir vor ein paar
Wochen schon gedacht, gerade weil Amazon auch ganz gerne mal so ein bisschen auf Charity
macht, warum haben die nicht gesagt ok, wir versuchen Twitch zu einer Online Unterricht
auf Twitch zu fördern, das wäre richtig excellent gewesen, man kann Klassenräume anlegen oder
sowas, weil die das normale Twitch schon nicht maintainen können, ja ok das kann natürlich
sein, aber das wäre richtig cool gewesen, außerdem hätte sich Amazon ein bisschen damit
brüsten können, wie fortschrittlich sie halt sind und dann quasi wieder die Schulen
dieser Welt unterstützen und bla und sonst was, stellt euch mal vor wie geil das wäre,
wenn du Online Unterricht hättest und kannst dann zwischendurch einfach posten, ja, das
wäre doch massiv, das wäre doch richtig geil, da würden die Leute den ganzen Tag nichts
anderes machen, wie wenigstens anwesend sein beim Unterricht und irgendein sinnloses Zeug
spammen, man muss aber sagen, seitdem Amazon Twitch übernommen hat, ist einiges besser
geworden, das muss man auch mal sagen, es wird viel Trash Talked, ja, dass Twitch immer
schlechter geworden ist und ihre Regeln komisch auslegen und sonst was, ist auch was dran,
kann ich nachvollziehen, aber auch von technischer Seite ist Twitch besser geworden, auch hauptsächlich
von der Server Kapazität, seitdem die bei Amazon sind, kann fast jeder zum Beispiel
1080p 60fps streamen, wenn das einstellt, mit ordentlicher Bitrate und auch nicht Partner
und werden nicht direkt runterencoded oder gar nicht erst angenommen, was, die Universität
Hof streamt regelmäßig die Vorlesung, ja, das ist gut, das finde ich gut, ok, wir haben
alles installiert für Chrome zum Builden, jetzt wird es sagen, G-Client Run Hooks, ja,
wir wissen, dass es sad ist, Faster Build, Faster Build ist immer gut, Faster Build ist
poggers, jetzt führt der erst irgendwelche Hooks aus, crcrabug.com, oh der lädt ja schon
wieder die halbe Internet nach, guckt euch das mal an, die Knuckle Tools, was auch immer
das sein soll, i ist das SVN, Leute ist das SVN, was ich hier sehe gerade, ist das SVN,
ne ich glaube nicht, dass es SVN ist, noch haben wir genug Platz, Extracting Packer, was
ist SVN, Inversions Kontrollsystem, was es mal eine graue Vorzeit gegeben hat, ja Sebaro,
SVN ist sowas wie Git, nur vom Ansatz her komplett anders, aber es fällt in die gleiche
Kategorie Tools wie Git, ja, SVN ist eklig, ich hatte noch die Ehre Anfang, wo ich die
Ausbildung gemacht habe und danach auch noch ein bisschen SVN zu benutzen, das war eklig,
SVN Sucked, ich glaube ich kenne keinen der SVN Mark, was war der Vorgänger von SVN,
C, CNV, CSV, CVS, genau das muss wohl noch schlimmer sein, ok ja es gibt immer Leute
die merkwürdige Sachen gut finden, aber SVN ist echt nicht meins gewesen, ok also wie
geht es, wir können schon mal gucken wie es weiter geht, Chromium uses Ninja, was hat
der denn damit zu tun, Assets Main Building Tool alongside with a Tool called GN, to generate
Ninja Files, ah verstehe ok, es benutzt Ninja zum Bilden, allerdings das Ninja bilden kann
man erst mal Ninja Files generieren, ich habe echt keine Ahnung was ich da mache, ist Ninja
nicht ein Templating Engine, war das nicht Ginger, war das nicht sowas hier, Templating,
Ninja war das nicht Ninja, hört sich so ähnlich an, kann man schon mal verwechseln, oh er ist
fertig weiter gehts, ok Hooks haben wir, setting up the build, GN GAN OUT, soll ich das jetzt
hier drinnen machen, mach ich das jetzt hier im Source Ordner drin oder wo mach ich das
jetzt drin, aber einfach mal hier drin, GN GAN OUT, ok hat funktioniert, you only have
to run this once, ja ok Faster Builds, use Goma, was zum, if you are not a Googler sign
up, ok das fällt schon mal flach für uns, das fällt schon mal flach, Disable Knuckle,
das sind Plugins brauchen wir nicht, you can set the GN Argument, enable Knuckle gleich
falls, ok so, ne wie setzt man diese Argumente, ich hab kein Schimmer, wie geht das, wie setzt
man, was bei denen, OUT, DEFAULT, wo setzt man das jetzt, ARKS, so, include debug symbols,
ja ok zack, alles Debug Symbols brauchen wir nicht, use ICE CC, ich hab keine Ahnung
was das macht, cache, Temper Fest, wir schreiben auf ne SSD, passt, ok jetzt wird gebildet
Leute, es wird gebildet, es wird gebildet, der Auto Ninja, hart top, wow, ach du Scheiße,
oh das dauert, oder so der erste Schritt, der rechner ist einfach mal auf 100% beim
compilieren, ok wir schauen mal nebenbei nach, was haben wir sonst noch hier, 3, warte für
ein IO, ach IO ist noch im Rahmen, das schöne ist, dass du so Builds ziemlich gut parallel
machen kannst, ja man kann Sachen wunderbar kompilieren parallel, Matt fragt, wird das
in einer VM nicht voll lahm, ne, die VM hat 16GB RAM, 4 CPU Kerne, 100GB Festplatten Speicher
und 16G Swap noch mal dabei, ja Flow 690 hätte ich machen können, aber da hätte vielleicht
der Stream geruckelt, war mir so lieber, so kann auf jeden Fall der Stream nicht ruckeln,
die CPU ist nicht virtualisiert, oder nicht so richtig, die CPU ist das einzige an Hardware,
was in VMs nicht so richtig virtualisiert ist, das einzige was die machen ist ein bisschen
Assembler Rewrite Magic, lustigerweise ist das die zentrale Komponente, wo man denken
würde bei einer VM, die virtualisiert wird, die CPU und das ist sie nicht, an der CPU
ist quasi nichts virtualisiert, oder kaum was virtualisiert in der VM, CPU Performance
ist 99% die gleiche wie auf dem Host in der VM, spätestensseits auch diese ganzen, nicht
die Krypto Extensions, diese ganzen Virtualisierungsfunktionen in der CPU gibt, ist da eigentlich kein Unterschied,
wenn du CPU Benchmarks machst zwischen dem Host und der VM, ist kaum ein Unterschied,
wo VMs langsam sind, ist wenn du IO machst auf die Platte, je nachdem, aber in der Regel,
wenn es über virtualisierte Sachen geht, IO ist langsamer, deutlich langsamer teilweise
als auf dem Host, zählt natürlich nicht nur Platte, zählt auch Netzwerk und alles mögliche
dazu, was potenziell in der Ecke langsamer ist und wo VMs komplett versagen ist in irgendeiner
Art und Weise, was grafische Ausgaben angeht, grafische Ausgaben und also mit Beschleunigung
und jegliche Art von Hardware Beschleunigung, was mit Grafikkarten und so zu tun hat, kannst
du vergessen.
Braucht man da nicht sowas wie KVM oder so für, ne, die CPU-Virtualisierung ist bei
allen fast das gleiche, was KVM kann im Vergleich zur VM-Workstation, ist das Durchreichen
von der Grafikkarte, wenn du eine Grafikkarte durchreichst, dann kannst du in der VM auch
super Hardware Beschleunigung und GPU-Encoding und sonstige Sachen machen, du brauchst dann
allerdings, ich weiß, dass es da Tricks gibt, aber von der Idee her brauchst du natürlich
dann einen Monitor, den du an die Grafikkarte anschließt und kannst es nicht mehr so verwenden
wie ich hier.
Ne, vor allem bei Workstation kann das nicht, vor allem bei Workstation wird das auch nie
können unter Windows, weil ich glaube nicht, dass es in Windows in irgendeiner Art und
Weise Support gibt für Hypervisor-PCI-Paththrough.
Ja, es gibt Headless-HDMI-Dongles, aber wenn du sehen willst, was auf deiner VM passiert
und das halt auch über die Grafikkarte beschleunigt, dann musst du es über die Grafikkarten Output
machen.
Oder du machst sowas wie, wie heißt das, Glass, Glass, eh was mit Glass, das da, das
kannst du auch machen, aber das hat auch seine Limitierung.
Theoretisch müsstest du auch eine Maus anschließen und sowas an die VM.
Also VM mit PCI-Paththrough ist viel mehr eine eigene Rechner fast schon als eine VM.
Also man verliert viel Komfort, den man bei so einer klassischen VM wie hier bei der,
bei meiner Lug-VM hat, wenn du anfängst mit GPU-Paththrough.
Hyper-V kann das?
Glaube ich nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass Hyper-V unter Windows 10 irgendwie GPU-Paththrough, PC-Paththrough
kann.
Das klingt sehr nach Wii Sports, ja.
Glaube ich nicht, dass es das kann.
Kann es nicht, habe ich doch gesagt.
Da brauchst du, das musst du auf der Hyper-V Variante von irgendeinem Windows-Server-System
machen.
Dann kann es das.
Okay, das leuchtet mir ein.
Wäre ja auch blöd, wenn es das nicht kann, weil die Konkurrenz kann das auch, aber das
ist die, diese Hyper-V, diese billige Hyper-V-Geschichte, die hier bei Windows 10 dabei ist, kann,
das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Und das wird Microsoft auch nicht wollen.
Soll wohl gehen.
Hyper-V on?
Das geht nicht, das geht nicht, ich glaube nicht, dass es geht, ich glaube nicht, dass
es funktioniert.
Windows 10, Hyper-V, PC-Path, ich glaube nicht, dass es geht.
Ja, da steht, dass es für Windows, da steht, dass es für 2016-Server geht.
Das bringt uns ja schon mal nix.
Das heißt, PCI-Path, da kann ich auch nix dran ändern.
Also, ich behaupte, das geht nicht, wer was anderes behauptet, kann sich ja melden, wenn
das ausprobiert hat.
Es nennt sich halt PCI-Path-Thru, damit ist alles gemeint, also sprich, es geht ja nicht
um den physikalischen PCI-Slot, sondern um die Adressierung und das ist das gleiche,
ob du eine PCI-Expresskarte durchreicht oder USB-Hub durchreicht oder sonst was, das nennt
sich halt nur mal PCI-Path-Thru.
Also, wie gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass es unter Windows 10 geht.
Unter Linux mit KVM geht es, unter Windows Server kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass es
auch geht.
ESX kann es natürlich auch.
Und wenn es geht, ist es definitiv nicht so komfortabel, wie es hier mit Forever Workstation
geht.
Ja, Knäherbär, wir haben es ausprobiert, WSL 2, grafische Ausgaben haben wir nicht
hinbekommen, aber wir haben es mal mit WSL 1 probiert, da ging es ja auch schon und es
war vorhanden, ja, aber schön benutzen lassen haben die sich nicht.
Was gibt es besseres hier, Nintendo Musik und Chrome beim Kompilieren zu gucken, exzellent.
Also, IO auf die Platte macht es so gut wie gar nicht, ne, aber es geht doch, ich hätte
jetzt nicht gedacht, dass es so schnell geht, der ist ja fast in einer Stunde fertig, wenn
es so weiter geht, ne.
Das hält sich echt den Grenzen.
Was sind denn die aktuellen Github Repos, die so trenden, zeig doch mal her.
Guck mal, diese Woche, was trendet denn bei Github, C++ Things, geht ja schon gut los.
Was ist das?
Ah, yes, exzellent, alles klar, das ist ein C++ Kurs, kann das sein?
Das ist ein C++ Kurs, das ist ein japanischer C++ Kurs, oder ein chinesischer, was ist denn
das, Moment, Google, translate, chinesischer, chinesischer, chinesischer C++ Kurs, die
Chinesen sollen mal ne ordentliche Sprache lernen, Google nach Google, ja, wie willst
du das denn anders machen, dann Google mal nach translate, translate, da findest du 30
Milliarden Sachen, ne, und mit Glück macht er den hier auf, aber wenn du Google Translate
suchst, klar, was du findest, also das ist ein chinesischer C++ Kurs, ich weiß nicht,
ob die wissen, auf was sie sich da einlassen, go interview, collection of technical interview
questions, interview questions, interview questions, ich hab mir letztens ein Video
angeguckt, wo jemand erzählt hat, also von den Amis, der sich beworben hat, bei irgendeiner
Klitsche, ja, und die haben sich da aufgespielt, wie als wären sie irgendwie Facebook und
wollten sich total abgedrehte Sachen im Interview wissen, ja, wie irgendwelche binary search,
Bäume und sonst wie geduld implementiert, weiß gar nicht, ob es das gibt, wo er sich
auch gedacht hat, ihr seid so ein richtig kleiner Furzladen und macht einen auf Facebook,
also bei uns übertreiben sie es mit Interview-Fragen noch nicht so, ok, was haben wir denn hier
schönes zu bieten, Facebook-Research, end to end object detection with transformers, ok,
das ist wieder sowas, da liest du den Titel vom Projekt auf GitHub und du hast legit keine
Ahnung, was es ist, end to end object detection, ich würde sagen, das ist irgendein Bild, irgendwelche
Bilderkennungs-AI oder sowas, ohne AI, doch AI, tatsächlich, robot go, go native cross
platform gui automation, what, was soll denn das sein, ist das sowas wie auto, ah, es ist
auto hotkey in go, das ist tatsächlich mal was, wo ich sag, das klingt gut, weil auto
hotkey ist von der Sprache her übelster crap, also die auto hotkey scriptsprache ist wirklich
grausam, ja, was, guck mal, das ist doch schön, das kann man doch wunderbar lesen,
das kann man doch wunderbar lesen hier, scroll mouse up, mouse click left, aber es ist wahrscheinlich
bei weitem nicht so featurereich wie, ähm, wie auto hotkey, auto hotkey kann ja die abgedrehtesten
Sachen was Windows angeht, wie haben die so ein Programm cross platform hinbekommen,
indem sie für jedes Betriebssystem, was sie unterschützten, in einen Zwischenlayer programmiert
haben, was quasi diesen allgemeingültigen Code in plattformspezifische API-Aufrufe übersetzt,
das war bestimmt ganz schön Arbeit, dass das funktioniert hat, aber das klingt cool, das
klingt nice, robot go, aliexpress fast jason parser für java, das kann ich halt nicht
mitreden, sweeter sweater, das sind die Leute, die in warzone im haus campen oder auf dem
dach, hast du dir schon mal kati 2 angeguckt, nee, ich hab aber öfters den 1er im einsatz
gerade, scharf, ist das scharf Emoji ist das, ja, alles klar oder, ich finde voll logisch,
mao make shirt, taobao, yingdong, stack cake, non simulated click, pc browser kann ran,
was, ist das irgendeine bibel oder sowas, ist das so eine art bibel, nee, ok ich hab
keine ahnung was es ist, ich hab wirklich keinen plassen schimmer, was das sein soll,
aktualise den translator, we are trying to clip you and make shirts, ich hab immer noch
keine ahnung, was tut das, was macht das, die machen wirklich t-shirts, ist das irgendein
javascript t-shirt designer oder sowas, das ist ein javascript t-shirt designer oder sowas
in der richtung, ok keine ahnung, was haben wir als nächstes, tai chi, ok eine extra
programmiersprache, programmiert in c++, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, note best practices,
das ist irgendeine anleitung für note.js, juckt mich nicht, k9s, sehr unglücklicher
name, kupanates cli to manager cluster in style, also sehr unglücklicher name irgendwie,
klingt, liest sich eher wie kupanates nachfolge anstatt kupanates cli, deep learning tensorflow
book, es ist übertrieben hart wie viel auf chinesisch ist hier oder, substrate, platform
for blockchain innovators, ah ja, blockchain innovators, sind wir nicht alle irgendwo blockchain
innovators, tail blocks, ready to use tailwind css blocks, das wollte ich mal ausprobieren,
aktuell mache ich ja die meisten webgeschichten hiermit, als frontend framework, weil es einfach
gut ausschaut und die leute sich halt sehr an, muss ich mal kurz hier ausmachen, an diesen
material design look gewöhnt haben, aber tailwind wollte ich mir auch schonmal angucken,
kennste, nee, was ist das, ach doch, das kenne ich, das kenne ich, so was haben wir
als nächstes den cwa verification, juckt mich nicht, auch interessant, jungle rest framework,
das gibt es ja jetzt erst seit gestern, cwa documentation ist eine corona warn app, ist
das die deutsche corona warn app, nee oder, doch, ist die deutsche corona warn app, ob
die sich immer noch hier in den issues gegenseitig anscheißen, dass die readme nicht richtige
genderbezeichnungen verwendet werden, da haben die sich nämlich am anfang, als das repo
neu war, haben die sich da, hatten sie nichts besseres zu tun, geschlechtersensitive sprache
in deutschen dokumenten, also wenn man echt keine andere probleme hat bei einer corona
warn app, als das, dann weiß ich auch nicht, die haben echt probleme, das ist auch irgendein
china ding, faster build system for modern web, snowpack, wie viele, wie viele build
systeme, nee bei webpack gibt es jetzt mittlerweile, 40, es vergeht im javascript ökosystem kein
tag, wo nicht 5 neue frameworks rauskommen, die alle sagen, sie sind viel besser, viel
schneller, viel geiler als die bestehenden und die nach 3 monaten 10.000 github sterne
haben, also es gibt glaube ich kein ökosystem, was so schnelllebig ist wie javascript, was
v2 raycore gegen den netzwerk, gegen den proxy, wo man firewalls umgehen kann, ok, etelwim,
intel wifi, ethereum client, wusste gar nicht, dass das noch ein ding ist, dachte das ist
alles abgekackt, der kurs, was hat cristiano ronaldo noch mal auf seiner webseite gemeint,
ich glaube monero oder, hat er nicht monero gemeint, hat er nicht monero gemeint, hauptsache,
der hat doch monero, der hat doch monero kryptowährung gemeint, pass ich auf der webseite, also eher
wahrscheinlich nicht, sondern die admins, ist aber eigentlich eine gute idee, stellt
euch mal vor, ihr seid admin von einer großen, von ein paar großen seiten, die 10.000 besucher
hat, und die leute lesen die seiten, warum soll die nicht einfach für euch ein bisschen
kryptowährung im hintergrund meinen, das ist eigentlich ziemlich big brain, ist irgendwie
nichts interessantes bei, diesmal oder, der internetarchitekt, auch auf chinesisch, das
ist auch wieder sowas zum lernen, aber da muss man sagen, da machen es die chinesen
echt richtig, die machen von anfang an, lernen ressourcen öffentlich auf github, das ist
eine super idee, ja irgendwie sind den trends diesmal nichts spannendes dabei, wenn wir
jetzt noch mal auf den monat, guck mal was unser chrome macht, guck mal, der ist schon
fast, fast, wenn man aufrunde zur hälfte fertig, natürlich immer noch 100% cpu last,
und nur 2 gigabyte, nicht schlecht, dino, ja, das ding wollte ich mal im stream ausprobieren,
das ist ja quasi das neue node.js vom node.js erfinder, aber ich weiß immer noch nicht
genau, warum ich es verwenden sollte, oder warum man es verwenden sollte, ich weiß,
dass es vorteile hat, wie eingebauten typescript supporten sachen, aber ich hab schon 20.000
mal gesagt, ist nicht gerade der riesen vorteil von node.js, dass du milliarden von npm packages
für jeden zweck hast, die alle mit dino nicht funktionieren, wenn, wenn, was, fantoy, bootable
usb solution, was ist das, nein du hast das chrome kompilier nicht schon verpasst, er
kompiliert noch, ist fast zur hälfte fertig, a new bootable usb solution, aha, damit kann
man sich usb sticks erstellen, warum nicht, ich mach so wenig usb sticks, design resources
für developer, powertoys, wir haben es gestern ausprobiert, bis auf ein powertoys war da
nichts gutes dabei, äh, kalmor, wir haben ein paar sachen abgeschaltet, die hast du
vielleicht eingeschaltet bei dir, so debug symbole und sowas, spring klingt sehr nach
java, view admin beautiful, ich verwende keine vorgebastelten dashboards, äh, kann man sich
jetzt streiten, ob das so beautiful ist, findet ihr das dashboard sieht sonderlich beautiful
aus, also mal, vielleicht, wenn man, wenn man so auf chinesisch optik steht, finde ich,
dass das beautiful aussieht, es ist alle überladen, ne, gcgboot, warum ist hier so viel auf chinesisch,
halb github ist ja chinesisch mittlerweile, terminal, das haben wir letztens ausprobiert,
zwift, dsbuild, ah, guck mal, noch ne neuer javascript, moment, was, es ist ein javascript
bundler in go, seh ich das richtig, jetzt wirds aber meta bei den javascript, jungs,
jetzt reicht es nicht, wenn man javascript javascript bundelt, jetzt muss javascript
schon mit go gebundelt werden, hast du eigentlich schonmal was mit placer webassembly gemacht,
ja, wir haben das mal, als ne testversion kam, haben wir das mal ausprobiert, oh, guck
mal da, xtl solution tv, hallo, hallo, ja, hast du dich umbenannt, hast du schon, hast
du schon immer xtl solution tv, warst nicht einfach nur xtl solution sonst immer, was
du willst?
ah, kann aber sein das wir mich verguckt haben, wer ist schon immer ok, wahrscheinlich hat
dir irgendjemand den namen weggecrapped, könnte ich mir vorstellen, ja, und auf wieviel
in streamtag bist du jetzt schon, lass mich mal raten, das letzte mal waren 50 oder so,
du müsstest jetzt etwa 80 sein, wahrscheinlich 80 oder so, aber bei mir ist alles gut, dankeschön
für den zapp übrigens excellent subscription 87 lag ich ja lag ich ja richtig ich hab ich
hab letztens letztens habe ich mal reingeguckt da hast du solos gespielt und es war genauso
beschissen wie solos in erinnerung hatte das ist so ein krasses rumgekämpfe solos das kann
man einfach vergessen also echt hardcore wie die rum sitzen den ganzen tag nur solos ist
absolut eklig ja ich spiele mittlerweile auch ab und zu mal warzone aber solos ertrage ich
ertrage ich nicht das musste er am liebsten ist mir eigentlich trios das ist nicht so viel
rumgestellte wie quads trios ist so die optimale optimale mischung finde ich bin mal gespannt was
dieses jahr rauskommt schlechter als der modern warfare multiplayer kann es ja kaum werden
am besten trio versus quads ja das ist das ist excellent it's big brain aber der multiplayer
dieses jahr war wirklich mies das sieht man schon daran dass die meisten leute eigentlich
noch schippen 24 sieben spielen was eigentlich auch totaler kacke ist aber aber fürs anlocken
immer noch am besten am nein was war das ist irgendwas kaputt gegangen ich habe keinen
bock den scheiß noch mal neu zu kompilieren warum fällt das muss hier wieder eine halbe stunde
sitzen bis es durchgelaufen ist ich habe keinen bock mehr irgendjemand hat auch gerade im chat
geschrieben was zum teufel ich ja dass die ausgabe sagt mir auch nichts ich versuche chrome selbst
zu kompilieren weil es geht hat keinen tieferen sinn aber chrome mag nicht irgendjemand im chat
hat auch geschrieben dass er das auch schon mal gemacht hat oder geht das mal ging das
bei dir einfach ok ab was was ok mal gucken kann man jetzt eigentlich an der gleichen
stelle weitermachen wo man aufgehört hat oder fängt er wieder von vorne an kannst
mal etwas über deinen stuhl erzählen ja das erste was ich über meinen stuhl erzählen
kann ist dass er eigentlich unnötig teuer ist dass ich niemand empfehlen würde ihn zu
kaufen aber nachdem du jetzt ja das dicke twitch subscription money hast dann ist das
natürlich kein faktor mehr das ist der beste stuhl den ich je hatte also ich habe mir den
ja auch nur gekauft weil wir den auf der arbeit haben ich kannte den ja schon sonst hätte
ich mir nicht einfach irgendwie so ein teurer stuhl gekauft auf gut glück den haben wir
seit fünf jahren oder so auf der arbeit oder ich glaube sogar noch ein bisschen länger
und so mittlerweile schon in der zweiten edition quasi und das hat mich so überzeugt
der stuhl dass ich mir den auch ein für daheim gekauft habe und ich finde es gibt echt keinen
besseren stuhl es ist kein gaming stuhl aber ganz ehrlich scheiß drauf ich meine ob das
gaming drauf steht oder nicht ja es ist schon ein bisschen teuer es ist schon ein bisschen
teuer also es ist der es ist unterm strich der beste stuhl den ich je hatte und auch
der beste stuhl den ich kenne ob er jetzt den aufpreis zu sagen wenn man ikea marcus
oder so wert ist weiß ich nicht
ikea kostet ja halt irgendwie 100 euro oder so
ikea marcus kostet 130 euro irgendjemand hat auch gerade geschrieben dass man mal nach
dings wie heißt der herrmann miller oder so suchen soll ich weiß dass sehr viele pros
herrmann miller stühle haben und dass das auch viele fans hat ich habe noch kein ausprobiert
ich kann dazu nichts sagen was mir an den herrmann miller stühlen nicht gefällt ist
dass die keine richtige rückenlehne haben die die komplett durchgängig ist sondern
so ein gespanntes so ein gespanntes so ein gespannten stoff so ein gespanntes stoff
teil und das ist was was ich nicht sonderlich bequem finde ja ich will also pisa preisleistungsmäßig
ist das würde ich nicht machen also preisleistungsmäßig ist echt nicht ist das denn das wird aber
advanced langsam das ist das ist mir zu kompliziert da zu viele zu viele stellschrauben excellent
musik ja also preisleistungsmäßig kann ich einen nicht ruhigen gewissens empfehlen allerdings
ist es halt auch so eine sache so ein bisschen finde ich wie wie mit dem mx 300 ich weiß
ich ob du das immer noch hast oder ob du das damals gekauft hast ich meine ich hab mir das
damals gekauft 2012 oder so das ist jetzt acht jahre her und das geht immer noch so ein bisschen
ist es mit dem stuhl halt auch so ein bisschen ist es mit dem stuhl halt auch das hält halt
ewig das ding und du kriegst dafür halt auch alle möglichen ersatzteile von polster bis
armen lehnen und so aber ich kann ihn halt echt nicht ruhigen gewissens empfehlen weil
das preisleistungsmäßig viel zu teuer ist wenn das wenn das ding irgendwo mal für 800
euro verkauft wird würde ich sofort holen aber nicht für den standardpreis eine sache
die ich aus ergonomischer sicht tatsächlich mal alle hier empfehlen kann inklusive dem
chat weil es gar nicht so teuer ist ein höhenverstellbarer schreibtisch das ist wirklich top
also höhenverstellbarer schreibtisch ist echt das beste ich benutze die zwei selten
zum stehen aber man kann nicht so hochfahren dass man stehen kann aber allein schon dass
man ein bisschen die höhe verstellen kann je nachdem wie man rum wie man dran sitzt
ist gold wert ich dachte twitch prime ja hat sich gerade so angehört ich muss sagen chat
ich bin schon enttäuscht irgendwie na was ist da heute eigentlich los muss mal kurz
gucken steams stats stream stream labs kann das sein dass man heute noch gut wie keine
subs haben was ist da los monka es doch mir schon mal ein muss ich gerade mal gucken vielleicht
habe ich auch dieselbe vielleicht habe ich auch die hälfte übersehen ja so sieht's
aus chat recent events wahrscheinlich habe ich wieder nur was habe ich habe ich nur übersehen
bin ich ja bekannt für ich den graben übersehen so also hi prunes hat prime subscribt danke
schon habe ich gar nicht gesehen und davor hat heute noch dann die lull ich hoffe ich
habe dich gesehen ich glaube ich habe ich ganz am anfang gesehen high IQ subs die restlichen
vorgestern das ist immer hier gab kaum was das ist so langweilig chrome beim kompilieren
zuzugucken kann ich auch verstehen gibt echt spannenderes ist eigentlich das command conker
remastered jetzt schon live heute mittags stand kommt in fünf stunden raus ja müsste
schon live sein also wir sind eindeutig hier geboren 1913 ist jetzt schon live anscheinend
ich glaube da werde ich nachher noch eine runde spielen aber nicht und stream
anscheinend finden sie leute auch alle ganz gut haben sie 19 euro ja gelohnt ja die stream
age protection ist komplett bescheuert ach guckt mal leute wir haben wirklich die hälfte
gespart seht ihr das der hat nicht vorher von vorne angefangen das ist die hälfte
der dateianzahl der hat der hat weiter gemacht an der stelle wo aufgehört hat das heißt
wir müssen gar nicht ich habe mich verguckt wir fangen gar nicht von vorne an wir machen
da weiter wo wir aufgehört haben excellent so muss das sein hat es im chat schon geschrieben
habe ich nicht gesehen ich habe auch meinen mein stream loggin loggin tool nicht an sehe
ich gerade habe ich dann irgendwelche fragen übersehen also leute wenn irgendwas wissen
wollte technik mäßiges oder so ich habe hier heute kaum zeit kaum gelegen hat bisher
gehabt mal ein bisschen zu schwätzen über kram schieß los ja ich treu gerade mal hoch
ob ich irgendwas übersehen habe was besser als dein heizungs pums knerbe ich habe keine
ahnung was du meinst kadi 2 ja wie gesagt kadi 1 habe ich im einsatz aber 2 habe ich
mir nicht groß angeguckt ich hoffe die haben die konflikt nicht komplett geändert das
nervt mich nämlich immer wenn sie zwischen zwei programmversion die konfig komplett
ändern dann keine ahnung wie es funktioniert ich glaube ich habe nichts übersehen
hier ist die italienische corona tracking ab funktioniert es bei den besser ich habe
es jetzt aus Versehen nicht richtig angeklickt funktioniert es bei den besser imuni ab excellent
name imuni ab official repository for ios version of imuni ab imuni ab hört hört sich
irgendwie ziemlich an die italiener kriegen das glaube ich besser hin wahrscheinlich kriegt
jeder wenn es um solche technischen sachen geht das besser hin als wir wahrscheinlich
sogar schiele oder so jeden fast jedes land kriegt das kriegt das hin und irgendwann kommt
dann der öttinger an und sagt wie er all sitting in one boat könnte euch könnte euch
an den kram noch erinnern woran wo sich unser digital kommissar hingestellt hat und hat
quasi in der eu seine antrittsrede gehalten hat hat irgendwas erzählt in richtung in
my home country baden-württemberg we are saying we are all sitting in one boat da habe
ich auch noch gar nicht aber exzellent moment
englisch wird die arbeitssprache in my homeland baden-württemberg we are all sitting in one
baden-württemberg we are all sitting in one baden-württemberg we are all sitting in one
Gründe, weshalb eine VM nach dem Neuaufsetzen eines Systems nicht mehr flüssig läuft trotz installieren Treiber
Falsche falsche VM-Version
VM liegt auf einer Platte anstatt auf eine SSD
Zu wenig RAM im System
Ich kann alle mögliche Sachen sein, aber es ist auf jeden Fall kommt es nicht so oft vor. Hast du dir schon mal ein Custom Keyboard gemacht?
Meinst du damit bestimmt keine Hardware oder oder meinst du damit Hardware also
Ich habe mir weder in Software noch in Hardware ein Custom Keyboard jemals gemacht
Welche CPU zum rendern für Sockel 1151 ich weiß aus dem Kopf gar nicht was Sockel 1151 überhaupt ist
war das der das war der Vorgänger oder 1151 das ist der Vorgänger von von meinem oder was ist was gibt es denn für CPU auf dem Sockel
Das ist irgendwas genau
Das ist der Vorgänger von meinem
Kann ich dir leider nichts zu sagen keine Ahnung
Echt die Corona App in Italien funktioniert in Deutsch warum nehmen wir nicht einfach die italienische Corona App und freuen uns dass es funktioniert
Kann man einen ESP 32 mit Rust programmieren leider noch nicht richtig aber die sind dabei
Es gibt schon so ein paar Proof of Concepts für aber leider noch nichts noch nichts fertiges
Oder mal gucken ob sich inzwischen etwas geändert hat aber wahrscheinlich nicht
Genau guck hier es gibt hier so ein paar Proof of Concepts wo die Leute auch
Vom unter rum basteln aber es ist wohl noch ein ganz ganz schön langer Weg bis das ordentlich funktioniert
Aber man theoretisch sollte das möglich sein ja klar aber man braucht erst mal einen
LLVM Backend also Compiler Backend für die Architektur
Beziehungsweise für diese CPU
Aber sie sind dabei ja
Was zockst du zurzeit so hauptsächlich tatsächlich zurzeit so gut wie nur
Warzone ja davor habe ich viel Pass of Exile gespielt
Jetzt dieses season aber nicht so viel
Und ein paar die ein oder anderen sache in steam was es so gerade gibt ja
Gibt es leute die sich selber ihre tastaturen löten bestimmt aber ich sehe überhaupt keinen grund warum man das machen sollte
Was hast du eigentlich als main os pures windows und dann vms richtig
Windows 10 halt für video bearbeitung und spiele kram
Und ganze streaming streaming zeug und sowas und halt hier linux vm
Und ein paar andere vms für gest warum habe ich noch mal eine windows xp form
Weil es geht wahrscheinlich
Ich dachte der Lieblingsspiel sei terraria wie kommst du auf terraria ich glaube ich habe in terraria 15 minuten playtime oder so
Wie kommst du jetzt auf wie kommst du auf terraria
Ja
Stimmt Windows xp habe ich letztens im stream installiert
Übrigens ich habe mich doch so über meine kosa tastatur aufgeregt und hat mir daraufhin hier eine logitech gekauft
Die zwar nur halb so teuer ist wie die kosa mir viel besser gefällt
Oder näher ein drittel drittel weniger koste als die kosa mir viel besser gefällt allerdings hat die jetzt schon probleme an den knöpfen
Ich weiß nicht warum die tastaturen alle so so so so crappy sind mittlerweile
Also das teil habe ich ja hier habe ich mir geholt von der weile
Und die windows die linke windows taste geht oben schon der belag ab
Jetzt schon ich habe das ein halbes jahr oder so
So ich versuche mal das bild ich versuche das bild groß zu machen
Ja die windows taste die leuchtet ja bei mir blau so ein bisschen wie hier ich habe ich habe ja komplett alle tasten blau eingestellt
und hier ist halt
Das so gemacht dass es durch leuchtet und das restliche ist schwarzer leuchtet nicht durch und hier unten
Geht bei mir jetzt schon das schwarze ab und es leuchtet unten blau durch
Wtf nach einem halben jahr wie kann die taste nach einem halben jahr schon anfangen kaputt zu gehen was ist das denn für
Komplett als crap wieder
Ich bin gespannt wie lange ich hier meine wireless mouse kombi hält
Als ob sie plastik lackieren es fühlt sich nicht lackiert an aber
Es leuchtet halt unten an der taste durch auf einmal und das hat es vorher nicht gemacht
Es leuchtet unten an der taste blau durch was keine andere taste macht und
Mit sicherheit damit zu tun hat dass ich die windows taste an der stelle viel benutze
Spielst du schach natürlich
Big brain excellent spiel
Ich bin gespannt wie es sich an der taste durchleuchtet
Wie oft ruckst du denn bitte die windows taste sehr oft seht ihr doch guck mal wie oft mache ich den hier leute wie oft mache
Ich windows copy paste und wie oft switch ich desktops
Windows taste dürfte eine meiner meistverwendeten tasten sein
Kann man link posten ja, aber ich spiele kein schach das habe ich nicht ernst gemeint ich habe keine ahnung von schach
Sind die best move vorbei ne da bin ich zu small brain für
Schreibe ein tool welches zählt wie oft du alle eins kopiert hast das ist eine sehr gute idee
Benutzte auch win plus v seitdem es das gibt du meinst sie die clipboard history ab und zu mal ja
Ah yes alles klar alles klar
Ah yes, alles klar, alles klar, jetzt weiß ich Bescheid, Jojone für den best move vorbei,
ein Schimmer, ich hab am besten keinen Plan, ich hab da echt absolut keinen Plan von,
das ist echt, das ist nichts für mich, exellent, nein es war er nicht, echt keinen Plan, null
Ahnung, du würdest sagen BE4, ok wie gesagt, also Schach ist was, das ist, da bin ich zu
Lowbrain für, da programmier ich lieber Assembler bevor ich Schach spiele, was macht es dann
mit dem Chrome Kompilieren, ach guck mal, wir nähern uns der Vollendung, Flo96 sagt
Schach ist doch Eats, ja dann ist es bestimmt kein Problem den besten Zug für Weiss voraus
zu sagen, Hansen schreibt, sag sowas nicht, das kann jeder, hab 3 Jahre gekifft und traffe
was, ja das macht ja auch deinem Gehirn nichts, deswegen kann ich bis heute nicht verstehen
warum da Kram nicht erlaubt ist, um jetzt, um jetzt, ich will nicht wieder von dem Thema
anfangen, ich weiß, ich hab das schon öfters mal mich drüber beschwert, aber ich versteh
es nicht, warum Zigaretten beispielsweise erlaubt sind und warum Leute quasi irgendwie
an den Hauptbahnhof gehen müssen und sich da in irgendwelchen von zwielichtigen Leuten
sich da was anderes kaufen müssen, also versteh ich nicht, das versteh ich nicht warum das
nicht legal ist, wahrscheinlich weil es kein Lobby dafür gibt, äh Kelmo in der VM gar
nicht, aktuell ist der Kram wieder vom Verfassungsgericht, ok, ich hab nen Bericht von einem gelesen,
der hat gesagt, er hat irgendwie ne Verletzung seit irgendwie 30 Jahren oder so am Knie oder
so war das, hat gesagt ihm tut quasi täglich, tut ihm sein Knie weh und die beste Zeit die
er hatte war, wo er irgendwo Südamerika im Urlaub war in ein halbes Jahr und hat sich
quasi dreimal am Tag, dreimal am Tag irgendwie den Joint gegönnt und hat er gesagt, es hat
ihm noch nie so wenig sein Knie weh getan wie in dieser Urlaubszeit, kann ich gar nicht
nachvollziehen, er wird wahrscheinlich auch sonst in ein bisschen anderen Sphären geschwebt
sein, aber wenigstens werden die Leute im Vergleich zu anderen Sachen, die man sich
in Frankfurt am Hauptbahnhof kaufen kann, nicht aggressiv, sondern die mögen sich alle
gegenseitig, ist doch top, achso der Kelmo verwendet Linux als Haupt-OS, ok, ja dann ist
was anderes, dann brauchst du nur die richtige Grafikkarte, den richtigen Grafiktreiber und
eine Seite mit H264-Videos, weil YouTube nicht standardmäßig H264 ausliefert, sondern da
musst du dir erst noch ein Plugin installieren, dass YouTube gezwungen wird H264 auszuliefern,
dann kannst du es testen, also sieht man mal wieder wie schön, super einfach sowas auf
Linux Desktop funktioniert. NoBadEnergy, ich habe keine Ahnung was spricht man das überhaupt
aus, was ist AYAHUASKA, ich kenne nur AYAYA, AYAHUASKA, AYAHUASKA, was zum, ich habe keine
Ahnung was das ist, ich glaube ich suche da lieber auch nicht nach Google danach, man
weiß nie was da rumkommt. Matt fragt gerade, das ist eine sehr gute Frage, ich fahre morgen
nach Frankfurt, welche Schutzausrüstung empfiehlst du für die meisten oder für die besten
überleben Beschonsten, kommt darauf an wohin in Frankfurt, fährst du über den Hauptbahnhof,
also aktuell musst du dir auf jeden Fall eine normale Schutzmaske mitnehmen, zum Flughafen,
da dürfte jetzt relativ wenig los sein oder, dann einfach eine normale Maske und gut ist.
Also Chat, ich habe keinerlei Bedürfnis eine Nahtoderfahrung zu haben, es gibt so ein paar
Sachen die muss ich nicht haben ehrlich gesagt, es reicht schon wenn ich irgendwann mal abkratze,
das kommen ja alle nicht drum herum, aber ich brauch das nicht zwischendurch mal. Ja
mit Obdachlose in der Bahn in Frankfurt ist gar nicht so schlimm, du musst nur wenn du
am Hauptbahnhof rausgehst halt gucken, da stehen die ganzen Spezialisten rum, direkt am Hauptbahnhof
wenn du vorne rausgehst und wenn du durch die Unterführung gehst auch noch. Max hat
doch schon Assembler benutzt, das kommt schon recht nah an eine Nahtoderfahrung ran, ja
wenn du das sagst, ich glaub dir das, ja kennst dich, was ist das denn, was ist das denn Sebaro?
WTF, Moment, sebaro warum kann ich das nicht mal aufmachen, ah jetzt gehts, ja warte mal,
das ist ja geil, das ist ja, das ist ja absolut Pfeifettidee.
Kannst du kurz erklären was gerade passiert, kann ich, ich lasse gerade Chrome mir umkompilieren
und es ist fast fertig, so ich würd sagen noch 20 Minuten oder so. Übrigens hab letztes
auch ein richtig lustiges Video gesehen, Mexican Cat Dance, ne keine Ahnung, das war aber kein
doofes Katzenvideo, das wär echt lustig, die meisten Katzenvideos wo Katzen was blödes
machen sind, gefallen mir nicht, weil es halt oftmals starkgestellt ist und im Zweifelsfall
die Katze irgendwie da Dinger machen muss die sie nicht machen will, aber das war lustig.
Ich guck mal ob ich das noch finde, wie viel Zeug auf Twitter gepostet wird, ich wollt
gerade auf Twitter einfach mal auf gestern scrollen, ne, kannst du knicken, du scrollst
dich kaputt, wenn du einfach nur nen Tag zurückscrollen willst, MonkaS, ich bin jetzt erst 21 Stunden
zurück und ich scroll hier schon 2 Minuten rum, eh scroll scroll scroll scroll scroll
scroll scroll, nope, Wahnsinn, ah hier das mein ich, das fand ich ganz lustig, du musst
die nächste Zeichensuche, ja, ja, musst du die machen, wartet mal, erst mal Pepe-Dance-Musik
machen, schön das es mega nice ist, vor allem wenn die Katze guckt dabei, Alter Mensch geh
mal nicht auf den Sack, genau so würde meine auch gucken, als ob Katzen so viel, machen
sie, machen sie Sebaro, wenn das so ein statischer Cam-Handschuh-Dings ist und die ne Weile nicht
gecampt wurde, dann haben die so viel, das ist übelst lustig, die Cat-Cam, ich könnte
noch nicht mal Katzen-Cam anmachen, selbst wenn ich will, weil ich weiß nicht wo sie
gerade ist, sie ist nicht hier bei mir gerade, sonst kann ich auch nicht rein, weil ich habe
die Tür zu, oh kann das sein, dass die Vorschau kaputt ist bei mir, hast du dir eine eigene
Version von Chrome gebaut oder was genau wird kompiliert, ja, ich versuche Chrome selbst
zu kompilieren, weil ich weiß nicht wie es funktioniert, ich weiß jetzt wie es funktioniert,
aber es ist halt wirklich arschlangsame, mal gucken ob die danach funktioniert, ach nee
können wir ja nicht, weil wir haben sie in der Ubuntu Container gebaut, da können wir
ja nichts ausführen grafisch, exzellent, exzellent, ich könnte nix Forwarding machen,
ich glaube wir kompilieren jetzt schon 45 Minuten locker oder, hat jemand geguckt, wann
wir angefangen haben, was, Fresse 2020, was ist denn das für ein total bescheuerter Hashtag
wieder, was, ok nix was mich interessiert, Immuni-App, ich finde den Namen immer noch
toll von der italienischen Corona-App, Immuni-App, das klingt irgendwie so, so, so, so cute chat,
genau was trendet denn sonst noch, das wollte ich auch mal ausprobieren, ja irgendwie nix
spannendes, nix spannendes, Immuni-App klingt eher wie 5G Bio-Shield, na 5G Bio-Shield klingt
nach Scam, Immuni-App klingt, Leute ich weiß nicht was ich machen soll, das ist so langsam,
ich hoffe es ist fertig bis 22 Uhr, ich bin müde, sag mal was können wir jetzt noch machen,
bis es fertig kompiliert ist, ich hab keine Ahnung mehr, morgen ist doch Samstag, ja
das stimmt, ey ich punkt 22 Uhr, ich geh ins Bett wenn ich müde bin und ich bin um 22
Uhr ziemlich sicher müde, weil ich heute wieder ganz normal aufgestanden bin, Schach lernen,
ach yes, irgendwas neues bei Cort, nicht wirklich, Ecomaten Conquest, also ich glaube Echtzeit
Strategiespiele on stream sind echt langweilig, hast du erfahrung mit Copanitis Bissell ja,
willst du wissen, kennst du CuteSpim für Arsene, klingt ein bisschen unanständig, cute, cute,
Spim, hab ich euch eigentlich erzählt, ich kriege eine Microsoft Azure DevOps Copanitis
Schulung, so halb freiwillig und doch nicht freiwillig, eigentlich hab ich keinen Bock
drauf weil die Schulung 5 Tage geht aber es war die einzige Schulung die mir irgendwie
halbwegs zugesagt hat, eigentlich will ich gar keine Schulung machen aber von den Schulungen
die es gab war das noch die die mich am ehesten interessiert hat und gar keine Schulung machen
ist auch doof, weil wenn man irgendwann mal keine Ahnung hat, dann kommt da mein Chef
zu mir und sagt ja hättest du jetzt mal eine Schulung gemacht, dann wüsstest du das bestimmt
aber hab ich keinen Bock drauf, oh das Cyrus hostet mich, dankeschön 135 Zuschauer, Poggers
excellent host, dankeschön, ihr habt euch den langweiligsten Stream ausgesucht aller
Leute heute, der ungünstigste Zeitpunkt ever, mich zu haus, weil ich wollte eigentlich mal
gucken ob ich schaffe mir selbst ein Chrome zu kompilieren unter Linux aber ich hätte
nicht gedacht dass das so lange dauert, das kompiliert schon seit einer Stunde oder so
und passiert nichts, also da kommt jetzt von Cyrus mit High Octane Auto Chess oder so,
ich weiß nicht was du heute gespielt hast, ach nee Visage Chapter 2, ich hab's gelesen
auf Twitter genau, ich kenn das Spiel nicht, ich kenn nur ein paar Videos von, das ist
irgendein Horror Game in Richtung Descent und rumschleichen und dunkel und erschrecken
und sowas, ja, ja hab ich gelesen, hab ich gelesen und auch viel schlimmer als wäre
der Stream nicht schon langweilig genug gewesen bis jetzt, sind mir jetzt auch so ziemlich
alle Ideen ausgegangen für den Stream, weil der Kram so langsam kompiliert ist, können
uns Bilder von meiner Katze angucken in der Zwischenzeit oder ich trigger die ganzen Viewer
durch meinen Desktop der so wahnsinnig aufgeräumt ist, IHK Prüfung, wollen wir uns wirklich
noch mal eine IHK Prüfung geben Leute, das ist aber Hardcore Content heute Abend, also
wenn ich jetzt schon gesagt hab Katzenbilder muss ich mal 2 Sachen zeigen, also meine aktuelle,
die liegt zwar nicht gerade auf dem Schrank, aber wenn sie auf dem Schrank liegt, guckt
sie mich dann immer so an bei, meine aktuelle, bis dann, machs gut, ähm, dann meine vorherige,
meine niedliche als die andere und meine erste Katze, wo ist sie, wo ist original Katze FPS,
da ist original Katze FPS, leider kein allzu gutes Foto, weil ich das Foto verwendet hab
um Chats abzudecken in MMOs, Katzenfotos, ja die sind alle niedlich, die sind alle niedlich,
ich muss jetzt sagen, die aktuelle Katze FPS, die hat mit Abstand vom Fell her das Interessanteste
von allen bisher, weiß ich nicht ob man das bunt nennt, ich glaube, ich hab irgendwo mal
gelesen, dass es keine männlichen Katzen gibt oder keine Kater gibt mit diesem Fellmuster,
weil das irgendwie DNA bedingend nur Katzen kriegen können, irgendwas war da, Hans00,
ich werd keinen Schach lernen, ich hab wirklich keinen Bock Schach zu lernen, ihr adoptiert
sonntags den Hund, excellent, big brain, ok Leute, also wenn es hier der Tayz wirklich
haben will, Artcore Content, Tayz hast du mal nen Link zu, ihr wollt ernsthaft, dass
ich ne IHK Prüfung mache, ja, ey hör mal auf, das ist IHK Geschiss, was, ULP, Feezy,
ja ich weiß, ihr habt alle demnächst eure Abschlussarbeit und eure Abschlussprüfung,
können wir machen, können wir machen, Testprüfung, mehrfarbige Katzen haben den Fall, dass die
Haare auf jeder Kleidung sichtbar sind, das stimmt, Unreal, zwei Monat, dankeschön, excellent
Subscription, dankeschön für den Sub, huge, ich hoffe, ich hab jetzt sonst nix übersehen,
weis mehr, wie man IPv4 auf Linux vollständig deaktivieren kann, ja, Susctl, frag mich
nicht ausm Kopf, Susctl minus P, man muss den Parement heraussuchen, das hatten wir
das letzte mal angucken viele erfolge bei der testprüfung das war mal unter
linux das bestimmt eine seite mit virus drauf die prüfung starten
oh jetzt gehts los kostenlose prüfungsfragen für fachen zeitlimit
auch noch mit zeitlimit jetzt jetzt hört man aber auf
ok chat also erste frage was bezeichnet ein cache speicher
die fragen stimmen nicht das sind keine typischen irk abschlussprüfungsfragen
die sind viel zu klar gestellt die sind viel zu klar gestellt das stimmt nicht also jeder
der die irk prüfung schon gemacht hat der wird wissen das stimmt nicht in der irk würde
erst mal sowas stehen wie sie sind sie sind mitarbeiter im systemadministration
team der alligator gmbh ihr chef hat sie beauftragt die unterschied zwischen
cache ram und magnet speichertechnologie herauszufinden ordnen sie die zehn punkte
den passenden ziffern zu was ihrer meinung nach dem richtigen der richtigen speichertechnologie
entspricht dann gibt es einen schritt b ihr kollege fragt sie hierzu wie es aussieht mit
der anbindung über ein nass erläutern sie die unterschiedlichen speichertechnologien
im hinblick auf den einsatz in einem network attached storage das wäre eine irk frage das
wäre eine irk frage nicht sowas hier das ist viel zu klar das ist viel zu viel zu logisch diese
frage das ist das fail aber wir können es trotzdem mal machen weil zumindest die antworten was mit
der irk prüfung zu tun haben also chat was bezeichnet ein cache ein cache ist ein sehr
schneller speicher mit verhältnismäßig kleiner speicher kapazität der als puffer zwischen der
zentrale an der cpu im arbeitsspeicher angeordnet das ist schon mal blödsinn das stimmt zwar das
stimmt zwar und wahrscheinlich wollen sie das auch wissen aber das hat überhaupt nichts mit
cpu zu tun oder nicht denn cache ist einfach ein zwischenspeicher ich kann auch webseiten aufrufe
cashen das ist überhaupt gar kein problem also ist auf jeden fall eins cache fungiert als eine
art langzeitgedächtnis des browsers damit können jetzt haben sie sich jetzt selbst widersprochen
schon wieder damit können user auch nach wochen noch feststellen auf welchen seiten sie gesurft
haben also wenn es die irk prüfung wäre könnte das durchaus stimmen aber eigentlich ist es
blödsinnig was der cache speicher bei explorern sorgt dafür dass immer die aktuellen data bei
explorern was zum teufel sind explorer mein die browser und leute wir kommen nicht explorer
für ein autohaus sollen sie typen bezeichnen information sie fahrt so in einem datenbank
erfassen welche der folgen typen bezeichnen soll alpha numerisch angezeigt angelegt werden
was alpha numerisch das hier oder hä bescheuerte frage welche aussage zu einer firewall sind
richtig jetzt kommt jetzt kommt big brain jede firewall ist immer auf dem rechten ein jede
firewall sicherungssystem basiert auf einer software komm ja logischerweise eine firewall
besteht immer aus software und aus hat ja auch logischer dass das ist ja das ist richtig
aber man weiß und fucked keine ahnung was die wissen eine firewall ist eine externe
fahrt für die den computer vor zugriff ein stritter schützte ok oh hey soll das hier
war doch nicht fertig oh das gibt es andere fragen gibt es auch andere freizeit kommen
ich weiß ok also ist sie internet small computer system heißt das wirklich internet dachte
immer das heißt ip das heißt faktor stimmt das heißt wirklich internet small ich dachte
immer das heißt ip ok was ist einfach waren welches nutzungen es jetzt über tcp ermöglicht
ja das zur nutzung von erstens in serve angebracht nein das lokal auf dem rechner oder dem server
für die steuerung von strc geräten nein weil ja dann das hier ok wir müssen uns beeilen
die leute zeit limit monka es programme die in computersystem einträgt unerwünschte
werbung einplanen nennt man gar nichts davon weil weil der adware trink nicht unerwünscht
den computer ein also die muss irgendjemanden installieren also beziehungsweise irgendwie
dumm anklicken irgendwo was ok adware was auch immer bedwear ist frage 3 für die programmierung
von zimmer reservieren in einem hotel sollen datenbankfelder angelegt bei welchem erfälle
handelt es sich um einen buchen wert vollpension ja nein was bedeutet der begriff fremdschlüssel
in verbindung datenbanken datenbanken hör mal auf please ist ein datenbankfelder die
in jenen dieser tabelle gespeicherten datensatz eindeutig beschreibt nö ein fremdschlüssel
ist wenn du von referenzierst auf eine an auf einen anderen primary key irgendwie na
ein fremdschlüssel das da b fremdschlüssel attribute das auf einen datensatz in einer
anderen tabelle verweist der begriff integrations test bezeichnen der softwareentwicklung die
buchse nach bugs im programmcode ne eine oder auch kann auch dabei sein eine aufeinander
abgestimmte reihe von einzel test die dazu dient verschiedene voneinander abhängig komponent
eines komplexes ja also mein ja also das ist teil ok lassen wir mal so ein NAS system ist
ein network attached storage das nicht an dem pc sondern direkt über einen switch mit
dem netzwerk verbunden sind nicht als backup system ok das da um modeling language ne das
da entwurf sprache für die softwareentwicklung ist um 8 storage areas sind im zahn systeme
sind im bereich der datenverarbeitung verarbeitung ein server der festplattensap nein ein netzwerk
zur anbindung von festplattensap system und täble ja ja frage neun wie viel zeit haben
wir noch btf wollte mich verarschen ok konzentration fahrbläser arbeiten fahrbläser verdeutlicht
fahrbläser dem als günstiger fahrbläser drucken lässt unter den drucken ja das da in der letzten
zeit vor allem was erinnert uns wieder zu der computer wir kapern ja im gegensatz zu nicht
darauf dass vom anwender auf eine der virus ich ok aber wir haben wir haben es bestanden
easy iets bestanden kommt mal durchschnittspunkte 40 deine punkte 90 welche kakknubs haben denn
diese prüfung gemacht was ist der ton weg wenn ich jebaited wenn ich jebaited nein ich
werde jebaited ton ist da jebaited der chat manchmal immer wieder immer wieder ja chrome
ok jetzt sind wir zur hälfte fertig kompiliert das dauert ja noch ewig ok ah guck mal das
ist wieder genau das gleiche keck ok da suchen wir mal eine richtige ihk prüfung test nord
schwarzwald ihk beste beste name nord schwarzwald ihk also die gibt es wahrscheinlich wirklich
die sind wahrscheinlich im nördlichen nördlichen schwarzwald ich lade grad prüfung auch nee
rumpel auf die kann ich im stream nicht zeigen das ist monka tos ich hätte schon längst
ordentlich ihk prüfung zeigen dürfen wenn die nicht copyrighted werden übrigens beide
darf ich euch mal sagen wie unglaublich bescheuert ich es finde dass ihk prüfung also quasi
die offiziellen abschlussprüfungen für eine berufsausbildung dass die copyrighted sind
und man sie nicht besitzen darf also nicht runterladen darf und nicht besitzen darf außer
man kauft sie sich das ist richtig massiv hängen geblieben log in zur testprüfung
ernsthaft ok wenn ich was über google finde dann weiß ich ja nicht ob es illegal ist
oder nicht ja ihk prüfung pdf was gibt's denn da fisi abschlussprüfung test ja nee
wird hier was drinne moment das hatten wir letztens erst das hatten wir doch letztens
oder das ist das gleiche was wir letztens schon gemacht haben das langweilig offizielle
prüfung was ist denn was ist denn bäcker das kann ich nicht aufmachen die seite ich
weiß das ist bestimmt monka tos bäcker aber aber das öffnen das sieht das sieht wahnsinnig
legit aus diese seite sieht genauso aus abmahnwelle monka es also wenn ich das einfach nur über
google finde dann kann ich ja nicht wissen ob es illegal ist oder nicht ja dann muss
ich ja davon ausgehen es ist legit da guck mal da nee das ist das ist die erklärung
das ist die erklärung dazu es ist es ist richtig fell dass man das nicht im stream
machen kannst es ist wirklich traurig dass man das nicht im stream machen kann ich weiß
nämlich dass es vielen leuten helfen würde ja stimmt sie bei auskönnte ich machen ja
die bäcker abschlussprüfung training aha excellent ok test fragen prüfungsaufgaben
Zack
Okay
Das ist aber bescheuert
Fachinformatiker laufen Sturm gegen ihk Prüfung von 2000 okay
Wieso Prüfungsfragen
Aha
Diese Prüfungsaufgabe können erworben werden warum muss man
Warum ist das nicht irgendwie allgemein gut oder sowas das ist so lächerlich in deutschland wieder dass man keine abschlussprüfung anschauen darf ohne
Dass man, irgendwelche
Monka tos probleme kriegt
Das ist echt voll der witz
Echt hängen geblieben
Ja sorry kann ich völlig kann jetzt nichts machen
Jetzt schach
Also was haben wir hier noch für fragen wobei handelt es sich sich nicht um eine skript sprache
dtml pyson ruby bp
Was
Was was ist das überhaupt
Bp l
Okay der chats ach de alles klar
Prüfen
Korrekt ich weiß gar nicht was es ist
Bei einem das ist das ist so eine typische dumme ihk Prüfungsfrage
Bei einem datenbank system bei dem die beziehung zwischen datenobjekten vom datenbank system selbst verwaltet werden und die objekte
Eigenschaften und daten von anderen objekten erben können handelt es sich um eine was eine absolut bescheuert gestellte frage
Das das ist so eine legit das ist eine typische ihk frage
Die ist so beknackt formuliert
Objekte orientierte datenbank okay chat
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt noch nie was von einer objekt orientierten datenbank gehört
Das ist die einzige die sinne ergibt in dem kontext aber ich ich hätte ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung was eine
objektorientierte datenbank ist
Was ist das weiß ich nicht?
Ich mache den scheiß jetzt seit
13 jahren noch nie davon was gehört also welche datenübertragungs raten kann bei adsl 2 plus erreicht werden
B
Ich doch aus dem kopf nicht
Ah was was ist maximale übertragungs rate bei adsl 2 plus
25 ich tendiere zu 25
20 25 25 klingt gut chat ja
Incorrekt b 20 wäre es gewesen
Direkt welche aussage zu den anwendungsmöglichkeiten eines vpn ist falsch
Lokale netze mehrere
Geschäftsstellen können auf eine sichere art über das internet miteinander verbunden werden
Wisst ihr was ich mache
Ich schreibe die ihk auf twitter mal an so schön öffentlich muss man das machen
Oder nicht die ihk irgendeinen verlag müsste man die die diese prüfung rausbringen die schreibe ich veröffentlicht auf twitter an ob
Wie es aussieht ob ich im stream
Prüfungsvorbereitung mit meinem meinen zuschauen machen darf
Mal gucken was sie sagen die sagen natürlich nee ja
Ok also
Lokale netze mehrere geschäftsstellen können auf eine sichere art über das internet miteinander verbunden werden das ist richtig der computer
Eines mitarbeiters kann sich per vpn in ein entferntes physisches firmen als hängen eine direkte bindung an einen server ist jedoch
Was was was soll was ist das wieder für den schwachsinn satz eine direkte bindung an einen server ist nicht möglich
Ich weiss gar nicht was der satz überhaupt bedeuten soll
Okay, das ist aber eine typische ihk fragen die dinger sind so scheiße
Zwei server können sich über vpn miteinander unterhalten ohne dass die kommunikation durch dritte eingesehen werden kann das ist richtig
Der computer eines mitarbeiters kann über vpn einen gesichern zugriff auf das firmenetz von zu hause erlangen ok dann ist b falsch
Aber
Aber ausschlussverfahren, aber keine ahnung warum
Ja was was ein satz der computer eines mitarbeiters kann sich per vpn in ein entferntes
Physisches firmenetz hängen das wort hängen an der stelle wer schreibt denn diese fragen
Eine direkte bindung an einen servers nicht der satz ist so hochgradig bullshit dass er echt nicht mehr
Prüfung kommen könnte das so fragen kommt öfters so fragen kommen öfters chat
So was ist der satz das ist so hochgradig bullshit dass er echt aus einer ihk-prüfung kommen könnte
Dass so fragen kommt öfters so fragen kommen öfters
Also ja ich spoiler ich spoiler jetzt nicht also in dem fall habe ich glück dass ich das noch weiß
Ich bin mir zu 99 prozent sicher ja passt warum die auch immer wollen dass man den kram auswendig war es
Oh ist das ist das euer ernst
Ist das wirklich mein die das wirklich ernst was weiß ich So eine kacke kann durchaus in die
ehrk-prüfung kommen 202 das ist ist das ist das was unter hacker paragraph läuft oder 202 b
303 a alles klar das ist eine bescheuerte frage oder
ok was gehört nicht zu den merkmalen des ppp point to point
dynamische ip adresszuweisung aushalte von sicherungsschicht parameter keine fehlererkennung
ok ppp das ist point point to point tunneldings protokolle geduld zwar irgendwie scheiß den
keiner mehr verwendet höchstens auch bei ppoe irgendwie dabei also nachdem das einzige was nicht
nach irgendwie eine layer 2 geschichte klingt ist würde ich sagen ip adresszuweisung das
passiert obendrüber nachdem die verbindung aufgebaut ist aber wieder aber wieder ausschlussverfahren
ja was das macht ip adress zu im leben nicht im leben nicht
im leben macht das keine ip zuweisung
also immer ppoe macht nein ppoe wird doch auch keine ip zuweisung machen da ist doch
garantiert irgendwas dhcp mäßiges dahinter oder und wenn ja dann leg ich halt falsch
ja für das intervall tatsächlich anscheinend kann das auch ip adresszuweisung machen das
hätte ich nicht gedacht ich hätte eigentlich gedacht dass ist dafür zuständige verbindung
aufzubauen danach macht halt dhcp drüber was auch immer ok was fragen aber warum muss man so
was muss doch kein mensch aus dem kopf wissen bitte nennen sie die protokolle in der sas standard
vorsieht um was bitte nennen sie die protokolle die der sas standard vorsieht um geräte kommunikation
zu meine fresse was ist mit euch los was sind das für fragen alter das ist ja wirklich da
kommst du der letzte depp vor keine ahnung b c alle drei ich habe keine ahnung ich würde
jetzt einfach mal alle drei nehmen weil die frage schon wieder so aus der luft gegriffen
einfach kommt und auch so fachlich detailliert ist dass ich sagen würde alle drei ich habe
echt keine ahnung dazu kann ich nur sagen wodurch wird die geschwindigkeit eines computers
beeinflusst das ist eine sehr schwierig gestellte frage aber so ein scheiß kann in der ihk
prüfung drinstehen letztendlich definiere geschwindigkeit meiner meinung nach alles
nachdem die geschwindigkeit absolut nicht näher definiert ist so also nur mal taktfrequenz
ist klar cpu schneller getaktet ding schneller größe der festplatte spätestens wenn es
eng wird und man ein bisschen zwoppen muss auf die festplatte ist die größe der festplatte
auch von relevanz aber ich glaube das wollen sie hier nicht hören bild wiederholfrequenz
jeder der schon mal den unterschied hatte zwischen 60 herz monitor und 240 herz monitor
wird wissen dass sich das ganze deutlich direkt da anfühlt aber ich glaube das wollen sie
auch nicht wissen und die größe des arbeitspeichers kann natürlich auch einfluss auf die geschwindigkeit
haben wenn du ein programm hast was viel speicher braucht und du hast zu wenig speicher und
das schwappt wie verrückt rum wird es auch langsamer also ich vermute das ist richtig
a und d weil weil größe der festplatte bild wiederholfrequenz für die ihk zu abgedreht
sind exzellent aber eigentlich ist es falsch eigentlich ist es falsch meiner meinung nach
nachdem geschwindigkeit nicht richtig definiert ist übrigens genauso müsste ihk prüfung
lösen ihr müsst nicht denken was wirklich richtig ist sondern ihr müsst denken was
ist richtig im kopf der ihk und das ist auch das was die prüfung so scheiße macht weil
wenn man wirklich mal ehrlich ist man könnte ernsthaft argumentieren und auch wirklich
mit mit also überzeugend argumentieren dass es alle vier sind aber wenn man denkt versucht
ein bisschen zu denken wie die ihk dann ist es a und d okay weiter eine frage haben wir
noch was sind hier noch ganz bei sinn wo soll ich das wissen wie wird die effektive isotope
strahlenleistung irp eines wlan gerät berechnet ok ok ok dass das da können wir da können
wir dahinter kommen da können wir dahinter kommen sendeleistung plus verstärkung eines
zusätzlichen verstärkers ja das klingt sinnvoll minus dämpfung des kabels klingt auch sinnvoll
minus dämpfung des steckers minus dämpfung des blitzschutz blitzschutz adapter mein
wlan stick hatten blitzschutz adapter wusste ich gar nicht ok a klingt logisch ok was
haben wir als nächstes elektrische leist elektrische senderleistung minus verstärkung
minus minus nee das ergibt keinen sinn das ergibt eigentlich keinen sinn elektrische
sendung plus verstärkung als zusätzlichen verstärkers plus dämpfung der kabel plus
dämpfung der stecker a ich sag a excellent und das ist auch so eine sache man kann sich
die ihk prüfung teilweise zusammen reimen weil es überhaupt nicht um die eigentliche
frage geht sondern nur ein bisschen logik weil alles andere ist bescheuert ich mein die
wollen wissen quasi wie gut wie stark das signal ist von einem wlan adapter im endeffekt
also senderleistung plus verstärkung ist schon mal logisch ja macht das ganze besser minus
dämpfung des kabels weil musst du abziehen minus dämpfung des steckers minus dämpfung
des plus plus gewinde antenne das ist das einzige was hier sinnvoll klingt ja aber was
leute wir sind durchgefallen warum sind wir durchgefallen mit sieben von zehn punkten
da waren so viele scheiß fragen da war er was macht mein chrome eigentlich das hört
nicht auf ist das langsam chrome please geht es immer der immer das gleiche war informatik
diese test test fragen da gibt es doch bestimmt noch mehr da gibt es doch bestimmt noch mehr
gibt es eine leseprobe leseprobe jawoll moment das hatten wir doch gerade schon hatten wir
sich letzten schon das ist doch genau das was wir letzten schon hatten das auf youtube
äh was da habe ich ja noch nie gedacht noch nie dran gedacht
dass es die prüfung mit video formen gibt die können nicht illegal sein weil sonst
hat youtube gelöscht
die hk prüfe offenbart wertvolle tips
gibt's nicht
es ist so schlimm in deutschland dass das nicht öffentlich verfügbar ist wenn das
so fail
probe probe ich brauche leseprobe gibt's nicht excellent keine leseprobe
folgspaket abschlussprüfung ja alles klar
lax was
einstellungstest gibt ein einstellungstest extra für fachinformatiker oh es geht direkt
los
was ist doch jetzt eher ein intelligenz test hier anstatt anstatt den einstellungstest
mit
oh bestes photoshop bild aller bestes photoshop bild ja
toni allerleute ich weiß genau wo ich die hk prüfung runterladen kann aber ich kann
die nicht im stream zeigen wenn ich die irgendwo runtergeladen habe als pdf wenn die jemand
anderes sagen wir mal auf youtube hochgeladen hat und ich gucke mir dort einfach die videos
an dann ist es was anderes
aber ich darf die dinger nicht im stream zeigen als pdf von der seite logisches denken zahlen
und buchstaben jetzt geht es aber ab ja die folgende reihe aus zahlen buchstaben ist
nach einem bestimmten schema aufgebaut ein element in der reihe ist jedoch falsch
welches markieren sie das fehlerhafte element was die folgende reihe aus zahlen und buchstaben
ist nach einem bestimmten schema 2n 4p 4,5 n 6,75 p excellent excellent wenn du die auf
youtube hochlädst und öffentlich auf youtube hinstellt und dafür strikes kassiers kein
problem wenn die auf youtube sind guck ich mir die an
das ist big brain frage leute excellent 2n4 ok das ist ein minus dazwischen und was wollen
die jetzt wissen welches element fehlerhaft ist also 2n4 verdoppelt sich hier ist
mal hier verdoppelt sich hier halb kommt die hälfte drauf hier kommt plus 2 plus 0,5
alles halbiert sich danach immer oder
das halbiert sich immer
alter was ist mit der musik los ah das ist das smash opening scene flow 690 keine ahnung
2n
das halbiert sich immer ich bin eindeutig eindeutig zu spät und bin nicht zu müde
für irgendwelche intelligenz test ich tendiere ja dazu vielleicht sogar schon das erste
falsch ist negativ positiv hier ist plus es ist immer plus es ist immer plus es ist
immer 2
das ist plus 2 dann ist es die hälfte war das mal
oh ne das krieg ich grad nicht gewappt ich war so test eigentlich ganz gern
ja ich weiß dass es zu 1 und 2 ist aber es ist noch nicht fertig
2n also wann kommt ein n es kommt ein n wenn sich das hier verdoppelt oder warte mal warte
mal warte mal wann kommt ein wann kommt hier immer das p hälfte n p und dann ist es mehr
n
ich hab keine ahnung in dem fall ich würde sagen der anfang stimmt nicht aber ich hab
keine ahnung
ja es kann auch nur zeit ich hab keine ahnung was wie man weiß jetzt gar nicht
was jetzt rausgekommen war das jetzt richtig
moment ach ich muss mich registrieren nee meine ich registriere mich nicht das müssen
wir morgen mal überlegen da bin ich grad eindeutig zu small zu small brain für
das ist mir grad zu zu kompliziert für heute abend
email abschließend und jetzt hat einer von euch rausgekriegt
das ist ein dieser aufgaben wo du quasi gucken musst also wie sich da irgendwie eine logische
reihe raus ergibt so chrome kompilieren och der ist ja mal zur
hälfte ist er gerade mal zur hälfte fertig ätzend
ich weiß nicht ob sich das lohnt
hört sich an wie in irgendeinem mmo einen heiler charakter der leute wiederbeleben kann
ich weiß nicht ich fand das erste video eigentlich ganz gut was er damals zur cdu gemacht hat
wobei eine sache die mir bei ganz vielen so wie nennt man dieses format auf youtube
einungskund two videos was mir da ein bisschen fehlt ist oder was da ein bisschen zu viel
gemacht wird ist die stellen das alles immer so als schwarz und weiß da als gibt es nur
ja oder nein und bei den meisten fragen in echt gibt es halt nicht nur ja oder nein sondern
meistens ist es eben fast dazwischen
wieso kompilierst du auch kaum in der vm wieso nicht macht doch überhaupt kein unterschied
ob ich das in der vm oder im host mache
oder ob ich das in der vm oder im host mache oder ob ich das in der vm oder im host mache
Cheat95, das bezweifle ich, dass das performanstechnisch einen großen Unterschied macht, ob ich das
in der vm oder auf dem host kompiliere.
Wie kommst du zu dieser Ansicht?
CPU-mäßig ist die Leistung zwischen der vm und dem host nahezu 1 zu 1.
Macht eigentlich kaum einen Unterschied.
Das einzige, was in der vm ein bisschen langsamer ist, ist IO auf die Platte und IO macht das
kaum.
Das können wir machen, ich hole mir einfach im nächsten Stream mal wieder eine digital
ocean vm mit 96 kerne und dann ist easy chrome kompiliert.
Das flutscht dann.
Ja Leute, es wird heute doch nichts mit comaten conquer remastered spielen, ich wollte ja eh
offstream spielen.
Aber das wird ein bisschen spät alles.
Nee nee, ach kacke, warum dauert das so lang?
Der zcrame kompiliert jetzt seit einer stunde oder zwei stunden oder so.
Wie läufts auf der arbeit markt, so wie immer.
Nix neues, der braucht vorneweg noch eine stunde glaube ich bis der fertig ist, guck
mal wie lahm das ist, seht ihr das, der braucht keine ahnung 20 sekunden für eine datei.
Richtig, deswegen hat linus und irgendein anderer kernel mann jetzt einen threat ripper
mit 48 kerne oder so oder mit 36 kerne.
Ja genau, ich wurde rausgeschmissen, weil ich bei der online erk prüfung mit diesen
sehr merkwürdigen fragen drin nur 70 prozent erreicht habe, was übrigens reicht, dass
man es besteht.
Dauert kompilieren von programm immer noch so lang, dazu kann ich dir eigentlich nur
sagen, dass chrome so ziemlich das größte programm ist, was man zurzeit überhaupt so
bekommen kann, also zum selbst kompilieren, es gibt, mir fällt nichts an, vielleicht blender
oder so noch, aber selbst das dürfte bei weitem nicht so groß sein, ich glaube es
gibt nichts, was länger aktuell dauert zu kompilieren als ein chrome, csgo sourcecode
ist public, du kannst davon ausgehen, dass der csgo sourcecode deutlich deutlich kleiner
ist als chrome, aber sowas von deutlich und auch der linux kernel ist deutlich kleiner
als chrome, chrome hat mittlerweile, was weiß ich, wieviel millionen zeilen sourcecode,
es ist eigentlich, wie gesagt, chrome und firefox sind mittlerweile eine größere codebase
als betriebssysteme an sich, also das ist wahnsinn, das ist wirklich wahnsinn, wie groß
das mittlerweile ist, was machst du gerade in linespray, ich versuche mir in einen chrome
browser zu kompilieren, also quasi aus dem sourcecode das zu übersetzen, dass ein chrome
rauskommt, weil ich so schnell immer mal ausprobieren wollte, wie das geht, aber es ist hardcore
langsam, code lines chrome, guck mal, chromium hat 35 millionen zeilen, 35 millionen code
zeilen und linux hat irgendwie 27 millionen, wenn du alles mitnimmst, also sprich, wenn
du jedes nur erdenkliche module und geschiss mit ein kompilierst, was man ja nicht macht,
dazu kommt, dass in chrome immer noch nicht mehr alles dabei ist, was in chrome drin ist,
also das ganze dhm und chromecast gedöns ist glaube ich gar nicht dabei, das ist riesengroß,
also es gibt eigentlich, also mir persönlich fällt jetzt keins ein, kein anderes projekt
in der größe wie aktuelle browser, also mir fällt nichts größeres ein außer chrome und
vielleicht noch firefox, windows 10, ich würde sogar behaupten selbst windows die basic variante,
also sprich jetzt ohne office oder sowas, selbst windows wird nicht viel mehr sein,
muss man sich halt fragen, was man da alles mitzählen würde, sag mal so, wenn du die
ganzen zusatzprogramme mitzählst, also wenn du diesen ganzen kram hier vom 3d viewer bis
zum media player und sowas, wenn du das alles mitzählst und den edge, man ist ja auch ein
edge dabei, also aus dem grund, dann ist es größer, was ist jendes entertainment,
ah der krunker client, beste, bestes game, so für zwischendurch ist das das beste game,
was es gibt, gibt nichts besseres, wie wenn man grad gelangweilt ist und nix geht, wenn man
eine runde krunker anschmeißt er, excellent, oh es ruckelt, oh es ruckelt hardcore, krunker,
ruckelt hardcore, weil er grad kompiliert und es sind keine leute auf dem server, sind die
alle, aber haut alle ab, kacke server, zackt, frankfurt, nuketown, alles aber voll search
game, nee ich wollte jetzt eigentlich gar nicht spielen, weil es sich nur auf spaß
angemacht, weil mir grad nix anderes angefallen ist, passiert ja grad auch nix, passiert ja
auch grad nix, es game ruckelt, weil im hintergrund cpu komplett ausgelastet ist und wieder
der typ hier mit der flagge rumjumpt, warte mal wie kann man klassen wechseln, nee, run
gun, excellent, welcher server, keine ahnung, irgendwie das erst beste, das erst beste was
ist, die op omp, wow, oh man, leute chromium wird nicht fertig, was mach ich denn jetzt,
ich kann nicht online bis chromium fertig kompiliert ist, kannst du voll knicken, bis
chromium fertig kompiliert ist, dauert 3 stunden noch, dauert viel zu lang, es dauert viel
zu lang, was macht chromium, nee, leute das kann ich heute nicht mal fertig machen,
stellenangebote, ja wir könnten noch einiges machen, aber ich bin echt ziemlich
kaputt, ja ich bin heute morgen aufgestanden, ich war jetzt schon meine 8 stunden arbeiten
heute, react auf die herr der ringe triologie, excellent,
0,5 geschwindigkeit per herr der ringe, extended cut genau, wie lang läuft das, 11 stunden
oder so, wie lang ist extended cut herr der ringe, 11 stunden, das ist total hängen geblieben,
12,5, nee, ok, wisst ihr was, diesmal mach ich die vorm wirklich nur aus und wir machen
das nächstes mal wieder an, aber ich kann jetzt nicht mehr viel länger on bleiben, bin
echt müde, und am start 3,30, excellent, ok, ich stoppe das an der stelle, aber das
geht ja, dadurch dass ich das suspende, geht es ja genau an der stelle weiter, wenn ich
das nächste mal starte, muss er erstmal 60 gigabyte auf die platte schreiben, weil wahrscheinlich
kompletter ram belegt ist, als ob das klappt, klar klappt das, warum soll das nicht klappen,
der kann die vm doch einfach einfrieren und wieder starten, das klappt, hab ich schon
ein paar mal gemacht, doch, der macht fehlerfrei weiter, überhaupt kein problem, ja, das klappt,
zeige ich dir im nächsten stream, dass das ohne problem klappt, Leute, wir machen Schluss,
ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen, auch wenn es viel länger gedauert hat, als gedacht und
immer noch nicht fertig geworden ist, danke für die subs, die es gegeben hat und wir sehen
uns dann, vielleicht schon morgen, bis dahin, machts gut, c u.